1 2 mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir bienvenue à la salle de la
palestre au cannet pour le grand meeting
de campagne des élections européennes
du 26 mai prochain un grand merci pour
votre présence nombreuse ce soir parmi
nous à la salle de la palestre au cannet
nous allons démarrer dans quelques
instants merci
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande à
présent d'accueillir dans cette salle de
la palestre au cannet michèle tabarot
jean leonetti eric ciotti
françois-xavier bellamy et laurent
wauquiez
[Musique]
vous
il
[Musique]
une une immense ovation mesdames et
messieurs pour celle qui nous
accueillent ici chez elle ce soir
michèle tabarot députée des
alpes-maritimes secrétaire départemental
des républicains
via mesdames messieurs chers amis quelle
grande joie de vous retrouver aussi
nombreux ce soir pour vous accueillir
ici au cannet pour accueillir ce meeting
avec if i grenet qui est parmi nous une
réunion assez exceptionnelle pour ces
élections européennes
je voudrais saluer avec beaucoup
d'amitié beaucoup d'affection tous les
élus qui sont ici ce soir il y en a
beaucoup
beaucoup de parlementaires beaucoup de
conseillers régionaux beaucoup de
conseillers départementaux de nombreux
maires beaucoup d'élus locaux
je voulais saluer les remercier
certaines viennent bien entendu de notre
département ils sont très nombreux mais
d'autres viennent de départements
voisins et donc je les remercie très
sincèrement
remercie aussi vous pouvez l'imaginer
tous nos militants tous nos
sympathisants qui sont ici ce soir avec
nous merci pour cette mobilisation
chérie c'est le signe que notre
fédération se porte bien et qu'elle est
toute entière mobilisée pour nos
candidats pour nos idées et pour notre
parti cette réussite c'est aussi ta
réussite mon cher laurent parce que tu
as gagné un pari difficile
nous étions attendus au tournant
certains prophétisent mêmes notre
disparition mais tu est parvenu à
rassembler notre famille
tout d'abord dans l'organisation de
notre parti et ensuite pour cette
élection
pourtant nous tous nous le savons bien
les élections européennes ont toujours
été un moment difficile pour nous nous
avions un clivage historique entre les
européens et les souverainistes
ge est parvenue à faire la synthèse à
tous niveaux d'abord sur les idées au
conseil national de manteau avec jean
nous avons montré notre unité sur le
projet européen mais aussi sur les
personnes notre liste représente notre
mouvement dans toute sa diversité je
voudrais saluer nos nombreux colistiers
et plus particulièrement ceux des alpes
maritimes avec bernard asso et xavier
[Musique]
bettel et tous les autres bien entendu
mais je pense que le candidat on parlera
et je voudrais saluer chers françois
xavier et tête à tête de lice et ton
engagement nous sommes heureux de
t'avoir avec nous
françois-xavier de l'avis de tous tu
mènes une magnifique campagne qui déjoue
les pronostics et tu ne donne beaucoup
d'espoir pour le 26 mai prochain
merci de porter nos convictions avec
tant de talent et tant d'ardeur avec toi
nous défendons un grand projet européen
pour la refondation de l'europe avec des
axes forts j'en retiendrai simplement 3
d'abord l'idée d'une europe des nations
qui respecte les souverainetés mais sans
tomber dans le piège du nationalisme ou
du populisme
le deuxième axe c'est de renouer avec
l'europe qui protège une europe qui
protège nos entreprises avec une
préférence nationale pour les marchés
publics
une europe qui nous protège des
attentats avec plus de moyens pour
traquer les terroristes où qu'ils se
cachent et par dessus tout nous voulons
une europe qui protège nos frontières
les demandes de visas doivent être
traités dans les pays d'origine et la
france doit pouvoir contrôler ses
propres frontières contre l'immigration
irrégulière dont nous voulons plus
enfin le troisième axe c'est de montrer
que l'europe peut être utile comme l'a
prouvé renaud muselier notre député
sortant c'était lui qui représentait
notre région
il a ramené plus de 3 milliards d'euros
de subventions européennes pour cette
région qu'il préside dans la continuité
cher christian oui l'europe peut
apporter beaucoup à notre pays
alors arrêtons de mettre sur son dos
tout ce que l'on n'a pas le courage de
faire en france les charrs nuit si
depuis vingt-cinq semaine notre pays
connaît le chaos tous les week-ends ce
n'est pas de la faute de l'europe
mais c'est bien parce que le chef de
l'état n'est pas capable de faire face
25 semaines que les forces de l'orde
auxquels nous rendons tous hommage
subissent et ils méritent nos
applaudissements
subissent un déferlement de haine 25
semaines que les petits commerçants qui
travaille très durement souffre et
s'inquiètent pour leur avenir
25 semaines d'image hallucinante de
saccage et de violence intolérable de
commissariats attaqués deux ministères
vandalisé deux bâtiments publics
dégradés
monsieur le président après cinq mois de
conflit
après vos trois mois de grands débats
qui a coûté 12 millions d'euros et après
vos 17 milliards d'euros de promesses
non financées
quand est ce que tout cela va s'arrêter
les chers amis vous l'avez compris le
combat que nous menons ensemble
aujourd'hui c'est aussi le combat pour
la france
nos valeurs nos institutions et
l'équilibré même de notre pays et de
notre continent sont menacés menacé par
les agressions extérieures et les échecs
de l'intégration menacé aussi parce que
nous ne défendons plus assez notre
civilisation
pourtant la défense de nos valeurs c'est
la priorité de nos concitoyens cette
conviction est encore plus forte après
l' incendie de notre dame qui nous a
sidéré
cette catastrophe a été le douloureux
rappel de la fragilité de notre
patrimoine et de notre culture des
siècles d'histoire est un symbole
inestimable de la france aurait pu
disparaître
en l'espace de quelques heures mais il
faut aussi voir des signes forts nous
avons d'abord eu un magnifique élan de
solidarité qui a réchauffé le coeur des
français par milliers ont fait un don
pour simplement dire je veux prendre ma
part pour la défense de notre
civilisation mais reconstruire notre
dame symbolise aussi notre désir de
reconstruire notre pays
en nous appuyant sur notre passé pour
porter un projet d'avenir et témoigner
ainsi aux générations futures de ce que
nous sommes profondément
oui nous sommes français et pas
seulement des gaulois réfractaires
monsieur le président nous sommes fiers
de notre terroir de notre culture de
notre patrimoine
et farouchement attachés à la liberté
mais nous sommes aussi profondément
européen
nos racines sont judéo-chrétienne nos
démocraties
nos démocraties inspiré par les grecs et
les romains et nous sommes parmi les
fondateurs de cette grande idée de
l'union européenne l'europe c'est la
paix la paix qui s'est construite sur
les cendres de la seconde guerre
mondiale n'oublions jamais ce don
précieux sellem du projet européen
alors mes chers amis le 26 mai nous
avons un beau rendez vous un rendez vous
avec notre histoire
rendez vous avec notre avenir un rendez
vous tout simplement pour renouer avec
une france forte au coeur d'une europe
forte
merci à tous mesdames et messieurs jean
leonetti maire d'antibes et
vice-président et républicains
[Musique]
merci michel et merci c'est le mot qui
vient spontanément aux lèvres merci
merci d'abord à michel de son accueil de
son organisation sa capacité à
rassembler sa capacité à faire que
l'accueil pour laurent et françois
xavier soit à la hauteur du niveau
ils ont mis et de la barre ils ont mis
très haute merci bien sûr à tous les
élus qui sont là je remercie bien sûr
dominique charles anges erick christian
henry
monsieur le sénateur vous tous je vais
pas citer les élus ce qui est important
c'est que vous soyez là vous les autres
voilà pour ceux qui ont choisi de passer
à un moment avec nous et que vous soyez
là depuis le début
traversant la tempête avec votre
solidité où que vous soyez revenus ce
qui est important c'est que vous soyez
là ce qui est important c'est que cette
famille soit rassemblée et s'il ya un
merci à dire un
un merci à dire à une personne c'est à
laurent que
merci parce que dans la division je
dirais presque dans la dispersion dans
laquelle nous nous sommes trouvés il
était facile de sombrer dans le
désespoir ou pire dans le fatalisme
après tout qui se débrouille après tout
ceux qui sont allés en face qu'ils
aillent en face après tout ceux qui sont
restés à la maison et qui vont rester à
la maison qui reste à la maison et
laurent tu as eu le courage de dire et
la volonté de fer et ces éléments là
sont des éléments majeurs pour un chef
on s'invente pas chef à un moment où
lorsque le désert existe lorsque le
calot existe parce que la défaite vient
des soufflets l'ensemble des toutes les
bonnes volontés il ya quelqu'un qui se
dresse et qui dit on y va on y retourne
et bien c'est laurent qui l'a fait il a
fait en rassemblant la première preuve
du rassemblement si j'ose dire laurent
et pardonne moi cet élément c'est qui il
m'a tendu la main
nous n'avons pas toujours dit les mêmes
choses n'avons pas toujours utilisé les
mêmes mots nous avons toujours eu la
même loyauté vis-à-vis de notre famille
politique
vous êtes notre famille politique et
dans votre diversité nous avons l'union
ensemble et cette diversité est la
garante justement la garante de notre
force retrouvée
merci merci aussi d'avoir réfléchi à un
projet avant de poser en termes simples
le fait de dire et qui va être le leader
parce que c'était bien la question
dis moi un non et non je vais te dire
une idée la politique ce n'est pas
uniquement une ambition personnelle et
je dirais que françois-xavier n'avait
rien demandé
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il réussit
mieux que les autres aujourd'hui parce
qu'il n'a pas frappé à la porte pendant
des heures et des heures pour dire c'est
moi et pas les autres
le projet d'abord ce projet nous l'avons
vécu ensemble et pas loin
nous l'avons vécu à menton je cherche
monsieur le maire de menton nous l'avons
vécu à menton
merci jean plus à dos et nous avons
défini sept piliers et des sept piliers
commencer par un mot nous sommes
européens parce que nous sommes français
et cet engagement européen
mettez fin à toute polémique sur le fait
de savoir si nous devions défaire ou
déconstruire non nous voulons construire
construire notre parti c'est partiel et
partial construire notre pays
c'est un projet construire l'europe est
notre pays à l'intérieur de l'europe
alors là c'est un engagement oui on
commence par dire nous sommes européens
et puis donc disons des choses simples
il y a des frontières c'est pas des murs
et frontières parce que les uns veulent
se protéger des autres
ils mettent des murs rappelez vous de ce
mur de berlin qui a changé quel
lorsqu'il est tombé et qui a ouvert le
mondre le monde communiste au monde
libre
et bien non la frontière ça dit tu es
différent de moi et je respecte ta
culture et je respecte à civilisation
mais ma frontière fait que je sais qui
je suis et je vais vers toi la main
tendu la main ferme est ouverte mais la
main tendue c'est ça la frontière eh
bien oui nous sommes pour les frontières
et puis et pardonnez du peu
nous sommes pour protéger les européens
quelle drôle d'idée
comment une mère quand il se fait élire
il dit je protègerai mes concitoyens une
région et le dis je protègerai ma région
le président de la france devrait dire
devrait dire je protège les français
et quand on se présente à l'europe on
doit dire je posais protège l'europe et
je protège l'europe contre la
concurrence déloyale
je protège l'europe contre l'immigration
violente je protège l'europe parce que
c'est ma civilisation
le mot civilisation est posée et nous
savons depuis paul valéry qu'elles sont
mortelles et nous savons que la nôtre
est en danger et que nous savons que la
note est en danger non pas parce qu'elle
est en conflit avec d'autres mais pas ce
qu'est la peine ça
affirmé quelle drôle de monde et quelle
drôle de société dans laquelle on a
presque honte d'être ce que nous sommes
presque honte de dire oui ce monde comme
le disait camus cette civilisation
européenne a été formulée sur deux
grands piliers
le premier c'est la raison la raison
cartésienne cherche françois-xavier
cette raison cartésienne qui nous a fait
avancer dans les techniques dans la
science et faire en sorte que nous avons
dominé le monde
excusez-nous d'avoir dominé le monde par
la technique par la science excusez-nous
d'avoir était prométhéens excusez-nous
d'avoir envisagé le progrès technique
comme une avancée pour l'homme et la
deuxième qui est peut-être plus encore
forte dans notre culture européenne
c'est l'idée de la personne humaine de
la dignité de la personne humaine
peut-être que cet élément là s'est
révélé peut-être après la shoah et et la
terrible confrontation du monde civilisé
de la barbarie dans un monde que nous
croyons que nous pensions civilisé eh
bien ces deux éléments là sont-ils
antagonistes non et nous n'avons pas
être coupable comme michel n'avons pas
être coupable d'avoir eu des colonies
parce qu'à l'époque aux avions dans la
tête l'idée que nous apportions la
civilisation au monde et ne raisonnons
pas aujourd'hui avec les idées d'hier
raisonnons aujourd'hui avec des peuples
qui sont devenus des peuples libres et
des peuples amis et pour lequel à une
certaine époque et bien aux pensions que
nous devions leur apporter plus que le
progrès merci donc d'avoir construit ce
projet
et puis après avoir rassemblé après
avoir construit un projet européen
il est venu le temps de dire et qui voit
là et merci laurent d'avoir choisi
françois xavier
je ne dis pas que tu l'a choisie tout
seul mais nous n'étions pas très
nombreux et je suis content que petit à
petit l'intelligence le savoir-faire de
françois-xavier la façon de parler
cette modération dans le ton et cette
force dans l'authenticité la profondeur
être à fond sur le fond eh bien merci
françois xavier de nous apporter à la
fois cette fraîcheur et cette profondeur
qui fait que le projet tout d'un coup
ils viennent et tiens ça n'est pas la
caricature qu'on m'a démontré
tiens ça n'est pas le personnage que
l'on avait dénigré
non c'est un homme qui passage excusez
du peu et philosophe
ça n'est pas négligeable ça veut dire
qu'il réfléchit à un petit peu sur ce
que nous sommes et ce vers quoi nous
allons et dans ce contexte la perfidie
des choses simples il dit que nous
sommes des déshérités
parce que nous sommes incapables de
recevoir l'héritage que nous ont apporté
l'histoire de notre pays et l'histoire
de notre civilisation
elle est née sur l'agora d'athènes en
grèce
et là est née la démocratie est là et
n'est donc l'égalité
elle est née aussi dans la chrétienneté
qui a dit celui qui est en face de toi
n'est pas ton ennemi c'est ton frère et
ce frère qui doit l'aimer est née la
fraternité et puis le siècle des
lumières à apporter justement ce soif de
liberté
oui je peux exprimer ma volonté je peux
exprimer ma pensée et personne n'a le
droit que je crois aussi elle que je n'y
crois pas de dénigrer mon opinion était
née la liberté cette liberté la france
l'a portée dans tous les pays d'europe
la portable drapeau tricolore la france
c'est la liberté et pour l'extérieur
c'est ce droit de l'homme et comme le
dirait françois xavier plus élégamment
ce droit de l'âme qui fait en sorte que
effectivement la france c'est l'europe
la france c'est l'europe parce que les
cathédrales de se sont érigés en même
temps sur l'ensemble de ce territoire et
que lorsque la flèche d'une cathédrale
vacille l'ensemble du peuple français
qu'ils croient au ciel ou qu'ils n'y
croient pas et tra capable de se lever
et de se mobiliser
et bien moi je pense que si nous sommes
là si vous êtes là c'est parce que vous
avez au fond de vous non pas envie
d'aider une liste
enfin pour que si vous le faites c'est
pas plus mal mais vous avez surtout au
fond de votre coeur deux idées fortes
voilà vous avez une certaine idée de la
france et vous avez une certaine idée de
l'homme
vous avez une certaine idée de la france
parce que vous savez que ce pays nous a
donné un héritage qu'on ne peut pas
gaspiller et qu'on doit transmettre à
nos enfants et vous avez une certaine
idée de l'homme parce que vous savez que
la personne humaine et la dignité de la
personne humaine dans son authentique
liberté doit être protégée et que nous
avons un mot en france qui est
intraduisible dans tous les autres pays
qui s'appelle la laïcité et qui est la
tolérance de la liberté de chacun voilà
pourquoi c'est avec une joie non
dissimulée que je dis aux deux hommes
qui sont en face de moi que je leur suis
très reconnaissant d'abord de dire des
choses qui vont du fond du coeur ensuite
de s'opposer au repli au la destruction
de l'europe et qu'ils sont en train de
construire patiemment non seulement
notre parti notre mouvement mais surtout
notre france et notre europe telle que
nous l'avons rêver tels que ceux qui
après la guerre se sont rencontrés l'ont
rêvé oui cette europe des peuples et des
nations
c'est en train de se construire il ya
des moments dans la vie il ya des
moments dans la vie politique
vous sentez qu'il ya un frémissement
puis un basculement ce frémissement il
peut être négatif et je vois dans vos
yeux que vous vous souvenez encore de
celui que nous avons vécue il ya deux
ans quand vous vous approchez aux parois
et qu'elles sont lisses quand vous
essayez de convaincre et qu'on vous
tourne le dos quand vous heurtée à
l'indifférence voire l'hostilité et puis
il ya des moments où le souffle
vous sentez qu'il va dans les voiles et
que le bateau va avancer et qui va
avancer parce qu'il a un bon pilote
parce qu'il a deux beaux pilote et que
ce pilotage va faire que nous allons
retrouver la confiance non pas
uniquement dans notre parti mais nous
allons retrouver confiance dans notre
civilisation est dans notre avenir
merci laurent merci françoise david
merci à vous tous vive l'europe et vive
la france
chers amis accueillons à présent notre
candidat xavier vic
[Musique]
merci merci à tous alors vous le
constatez c'est ce soir ma première quel
meilleur bizutage que de parler après
jean leonetti tout ce que je pourrais
dire ne paraîtra qu'insignifiant ou ou
bien moindre alors je vais commencer par
vous raconter une petite histoire hier
soir lorsque j'ai quitté mon bureau à
grasse puisque pour ce qu'ils ne savent
pas je suis pompier
j'ai eu un coup de fil qui me disaient
j'ai reçu un coup de fil des liasses qui
me disait laurent wauquiez tiens à ce
que chaque candidat et la liberté de
s'exprimer et de prendre la parole sur
scène alors je vais commencer par
souligner ça parce qu' il n'était pas
obligé de le faire
merci laurent de nous apporter à chacun
cette considération
merci cher président d'avoir permis à la
droite
comme disait eric de revenir merci
d'avoir nommé françois xavier bellamy
pour porter cette liste ce si bel esprit
qui fait tant de bien à la droite
républicaine
merci également d'avoir permis à ma
génération de prendre sa part et de
venir à côtés d'agnès evren aux côtés
d'arnaud danjean de tous les autres mais
les avec l'expérience de bernard asso
qui fut mon professeur de droit et de
tant d'autres
merci de nous permettre de défendre ce
projet car les enjeux pour ma génération
et nos générations à venir sont nombreux
ils sont écologiques
ils sont migratoires ils sont
économiques face à ceux qui qui voulait
peut-être qu'ils pensaient que nous
allions disparaître cela ce sont ceux
qui veulent enfermer les français dans
un duel entre les arrivistes de madame
loiseau et ses troubles de la mémoire
et de l'autre côté les opportunistes qui
suivent le jeune bardella vous savez
celui dont le seul programme pour
l'instant est de faire pleurer castaner
le 26 mai tout un programme
mais en même temps quand votre chef de
file à l'entre-deux tours de la
présidentielle cherche les envahisseurs
à quoi pouvez-vous vous attendre
d'autres alors je vais être court parce
que d'abord gens je crois absolument
tout dit mais je vais remercier tous
ceux qui sont ici aujourd'hui autour de
nous parce qu'avant toute chose mois à
35 ans je suis un militant et je sais
pour connaître l'appareil de l'intérieur
que s'il n'y a pas les petites mains
pour venir mettre les papiers les
drapeaux s'il n'y a pas les jeunes qui
sont derrière nous et qui nous
soutiennent eh bien finalement notre
engagement ne vaut rien merci à vous
tous
peut-être merci d'avoir fait cet accueil
à françois xavier à laurent dans les
alpes maritimes puisque nous nous le
savions mais eux le découvre désormais
le plus beau département de france c'est
bien entendu le nôtre et je vous donne
rendez vous le 26 mai parce que c'est
grâce à vous et uniquement si vous êtes
avec nous que nous permettrons à la
droite de retrouver la place qui doit
être la sienne en france à la france de
retrouver sa place dans l'union
européenne pour enfin refonder l'europe
et rétablir la france
mesdames et messieurs veuillez également
accueillir notre candidat bernard asso
[Musique]
je vais vous dire que c'est un honneur
c'est un honneur d'être sur la liste
européenne et que laurent wauquiez mais
fait confiance qu eric ciotti et
apporter aussi son soutien à cela et
d'avoir la chance de combattre à côté de
françois lamy c'est un honneur c'est à
d'autres meneurs pour moi aussi de
représenter le sud imaginaire d'ailleurs
sachez que la culture européenne à
civilisation européens à son berceau ici
les phocéens de marseille à
saint-honorat et des grecs et des
romains
jean l'a dit mais nous nous avons ainsi
une tradition un esprit libre
une organisation d'un pensée et en même
temps la certitude qu'il n'ya de
création que dans la rupture est
quelquefois la rupture elle bien d'un
événement qui est celui d'une défaite et
c'est la rupture avec les habitudes
c'est la rupture avec les certitudes
c'est la rupture avec les sentiments
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre solution qu'une
seule voix banon il y en ad'autres de
voix et vous l'avez trouvée j'ai donc un
honneur de combattre à vos côtés pour
une vision de l'europe qui est celle
d'une europe puissance a enfin enfin ce
mot on a eu du temps entendre une europe
ventre mou on a eu du temps entendre
l'idée que l'europe était composé de
consommateurs idéalisé en estomac sur
pattes
on a eu du temps à attendre qu'enfin on
puisse parler de réciprocité de
préférence communautaire d'ériger des
frontières nationales quand les
frontières européennes ne tiennent pas
le choc
on a eu du temps enfin attendre que nous
d'yves que les normes comme le disait
pompidou il faut pas kittin et je suis
plus polis lui les français avec les
obligations de normes laissez les
travailler laissez nous travailler
et c'est la liberté car les lumières
nous devrons a pris la liberté et la
raison est la raison pour moi le citoyen
est aussi important que l'homme est pour
nous peut-être plus important que
l'homme est républicain français
c'est un aristocrate de la raison
l'émotion ne doit pas être la référence
la pensée doit être la pérennité la
projection dans l'histoire la projection
dans le temps et c'est maintenant que ça
se joue au milieu d'une mâchoire composé
des états unis d'amérique et de la chine
conquérante
alors merci merci aussi d'avoir restauré
la droite républicaine avec ses alliés
les centristes patriotes
merci d'avoir restauré les principes qui
nous fondent la nation
l'autorité la liberté une fiscalité qui
respecte le travail le respect des
anciens je pense que le président qui
nous gouvernent vous à malmener vous les
anciens
il n'y a pas un seul retraité qui a
survécu pas un seul et puis le statut de
la femme
et nous avons une religion concurrentes
qui peut-être ne partagent pas notre
vision de la femme il est bon de le
rappeler et le reste
que dans l'espoir qui est le nôtre deux
victoires qui nous permettent d'affirmer
à nouveau que nous sommes un courant
politique qui n'est pas des simplement
1958 c'est le courant de ce qu'on
appelle dans mon jargon de professeurs
le bonapartisme républicain un chef une
vision et la république et ses valeurs
alors merci pas ça va me permettre
d'être patriote et républicains mais
aussi européens
ces messieurs accueillons à présent eric
ciotti député et président des
républicains des alpes maritimes
[Musique]
amis mes chers amis quel bonheur oui
quel bonheur quelle joie quelle émotion
de nous retrouver ce soir en famille
dans cette belle famille des
républicains
tout simplement ça fait du bien ça fait
du bien de vous voir si nombreux réunis
rassemblés ici au cannet merci à michèle
tabarot pour son accueil chez elle
merci à notre premier vice président
jean leonetti qui incarne cette vision
du rassemblement dans la diversité de
notre famille politique
je suis heureux ce soir heureux et fiers
de vous accueillir dans les alpes
maritimes
en tant que président de la première
fédération des républicains de france
oui mes habits grâce à vous grâce à ses
onze mille militants du littoral de la
montagne de l'ouest de l'est du
département
mon cher henri mon cher jean claude qui
forment cette grande famille
vous êtes là vous êtes là et du fond du
coeur je veux vous en remercier merci au
président du département
mon ami charles ange ginésy qui préside
aujourd'hui cette grande collectivité
cette grande et belle collectivités dont
la gestion exemplaire que nous avons
conduite ensemble depuis dix ans charles
ange a permis depuis 2009 la baisse des
dépenses publiques
la baisse du nombre de fonctionnaires la
baisse de la dette et des doors la
baisse des impôts
c'est un exemple à suivre merci du fond
du coeur à nos candidats
xavier et puis bernard asso merci
bernard tu incarnes pour nous
l'espérance d'avoir enfin dans les
alpes-maritimes
un député européen et tu seras député
européen
le 26 mai prochain mes chers amis mes
chers amis votre présence si nombreuse
dans cette belle salle de la palestre
symbolise le vent porteur qui souffle
sur notre famille depuis quelques
semaines depuis deux ans mes amis le
chemin que nous avons parcouru est
d'autant plus extraordinaire qu'il a été
périlleux et escarpée mes amis vous
n'avez jamais douté
vous vous n'avez jamais douté vous
n'avez jamais céder au mirage macro nist
et à la farce du nouveau monde
vous êtes vous êtes militant des
républicains mais bien au delà
vous êtes surtout les militants de la
france de cette france que nous aimons
par dessus tout mais si nous avons
surmonté ces épreuves
c'est aussi et surtout grâce à notre
président grâce à laurent wauquiez
merci laurent merci laurent
je ne voulais pas que je te remercie
mais je vais le faire quand même
c'est mon côté rebelle depuis son
élection
tu a reconstruit notre famille pierre
après pierre tu as démontré que la
droite ne devait plus baisser la tête ni
se soumettre au politiquement correct
alors oui si la droite est de retour
après tant d'épreuves
c'est à toi qu'on le doit
laurent dès le lendemain de ces
européennes de dévots de nouveaux défis
nous attendent à toi d'ouvrir la voie
l'avenir tu appelles j'en suis
profondément convaincu et je veux te
dire que je serai derrière toi de toutes
mes forces pour préparer cet avenir
en choisissant françois-xavier bel ami
tu as déjà démontré la capacité à offrir
une colonne vertébrale idéologique à la
droite ce choix courageux et audacieux
c'est le tien oui mes amis
françois-xavier bellamy et de droite
certains s'en sont étonnés
d'autres nous l'ont reproché
extraordinairement étonnant que dans un
parti qui s'affirme de droite
républicaine notre candidat soit de
droite ça choque est néanmoins certain
eh bien oui oui françois xavier et de
droite ont la caricature et on l'a
attaqué
c'est le meilleur des symboles et c'est
le meilleur des signes pour l'avenir
merci françois xavier pour ce dynamisme
que tu insuffle à cette belle campagne
alors que le nouveau monde s'offre dans
le monde sombre dans le grotesque
en choisissant une candidate qui
prétendent éradiquer l'extrême droite
alors qu'elle en était originaire tu
incarnes à la fidélité la fidélité à des
valeurs à des idées à une nation à une
civilisation
alors oui avec toi et derrière laurent
nous allons gagner
en français on français qui hésitent qui
doutent encore et diana à ceux qui
restent arrimés au titanic macro nist
je vous demande de leur poser deux
questions très simples
deux questions quel est le bilan de
monsieur macron depuis deux ans première
question qui peut demain incarner une
alternative crédible et responsable
après ce naufrage le bilan mes amis nous
le subissons
vous le connaissez des paroles des
débats sans fin des images des slogans
des comités des commissions des mea
culpa encore aujourd'hui notre brillant
ministre de l'intérieur qui indique ne
pas avoir maîtrisé sa parole ne pas
avoir bien apprécié la situation
oui il a menti ou il ne connaissait pas
la réalité des faits dans les deux cas
c'est extrêmement grave pour quelqu'un
qui est supposé protéger les français
bref nous sommes face à une grande
illusion
où sont les actes où sont les résultats
macro aujourd'hui c'est plus de déficits
c'est plus de dette
un niveau record de chômage en europe
une croissance parmi les plus faibles
macron aujourd'hui c'est plus
d'immigration 262000 titre de séjour
accordés en 2018
un record dans l'histoire de france 122
mille demandeurs d'asile 22 % de plus
qu'en 2010 est là encore un record dans
l'histoire de france
si ces chiffres continuent au même
rythme eh bien nous accueillerons dans
ce quinquennat macron deux millions et
demi d'étrangers supplémentaires en
situation régulière
sans parler de ceux qui sont arrivés en
situation illégale
c'est totalement suicidaire macro mes
amis c'est aussi plus d'impôts je ne
sais pas s'il y a des retraités dans
cette salle
vous me paraissez tous animés par cette
jeunesse de l' enthousiasme mais si
jamais il y avait un retraité il saurait
mieux que quiconque combien son pouvoir
d'achat a été sévèrement écornée a été
durement touchée de retraités sur trois
depuis 2010 est ont vu leur pouvoir
d'achat a reculé
c'est indigne c'est injuste à l'égard de
ceux auxquels nous devons une légitime
reconnaissance à l'égard de ceux qui ont
travaillé toute leur vie pour la nation
à l'égard de ceux qui nous ont transmis
des repères des valeurs un héritage plus
d'impôts si pour les automobilistes
avec cette augmentation des taxes qui
elle n'a pas été effacée et à nouveau
depuis quelques jours le prix des
carburants franchi des records
une augmentation d'impôts pour les
propriétaires et notamment ceux qui ont
subi
l'augmentation de la taxe foncière et
puis au final une augmentation pour tous
les français puisque si nous avons gagné
la coupe du monde de football en 2018
et bien malheureusement nous avons
remporté un autre championnat
celui-là bien moins glorieux puisque
nous sommes devenus le champion du monde
des impôts et des taxes
mais macron mes amis c'est aussi un
président qui a divisé qui a
profondément divisé les français
un président qui au final a abîmé la
france et qui a laissé michel le disait
s'installer depuis maintenant près de
six mois
la violence dans la rue qui a fracturé
la france avec ces images terrifiantes
que nous subissons chaque semaine deux
policiers agressés de commerces pillés
de magasins vandalisés mes amis le 26
mai prochain
nous devons envoyer un préavis très
clair le premier préavis électorale pour
signifier à monsieur macron que la fin
de son bail va approcher mais nous
devons aussi mais nous devrons aussi mes
chers compagnons aller pour certains ce
mot nous parle
nous devrons aussi offrir une vraie
espérance aux français qui d'autre
laurent que les républicains pourraient
incarner cette alternance responsable et
crédible
sûrement pas les extrêmes ils se sont
discrédités et ils ont marqué leur
incompétence pour moi dans cette
campagne européenne
il n'y a qu'un seul chemin et il n'y a
qu'un seul dessein kin wah doo guider
c'est celui de la france pour nous la
nation française ne sera jamais un objet
d huez arrangé au musée de l'histoire
défendre la france c'est choisir une
europe mieux protégés avec des
frontières établies et sûr non mes amis
le danger pour notre civilisation
ce n'est pas d'aimer notre nation ce
n'est pas non plus d'aimer sa nation
comme le prétend emmanuel macron le
véritable danger c'est bien la
disparition des nations
et la disparition de l'europe et qui
menace aujourd'hui cette civilisation
qui menacent nos nations si ce n'est
cette f cet islamisme cet extrémisme
islamiste que nous avons le devoir
l'exigence l'impératif catégorie de
combattre de toutes nos forces
oui le meilleur rempart contre la
barbarie islamiste
c'est d'assumer ce que nous sommes l'âme
européenne
ces roms c'est paris c'est la tène la
mort aux pnc l'esprit des cathédrales la
philosophie des lumières le respect de
la femme la liberté de croire ou de ne
pas croire
l'alliance de nos racines chrétiennes et
des lumières est ce que l'âme européenne
va choisir de résister aux forces qui
menacent son existence
nous en doutons en tout cas lorsque l'on
regarde du côté des marcheurs
quand les ministres castaner et l'oiseau
assimile le voile islamique à la voile
est de mère teresa quand marlène scapa
extraordinaire compare les militants de
la manif pour tous à des djihadistes
quand le gouvernement refuse d'expulser
les quatre huiles étrangers radicaliser
qui représente pour nous et on les
connaît une menace grave pour notre
sécurité
alors oui avec les républicains nous
voulons tout simplement que la france
reste la france et nous voulons que
l'europe reste l'europe nous voulons
transmettre et ce mot est beau françois
xavier et tu l'a souvent théorisé nous
voulons transmettre à nos enfants des
repères des valeurs un mode de vie notre
culture notre langue
bref notre civilisation nous voulons
nous voulons que le drapeau tricolore
celui qui nous émeut celui qui nous
rassemble celui qui nous fédère celui
qui nous rappelle notre histoire le
combat glorieux de ceux qui ont versé
leur sang pour nos libertés
oui nous voulons que ce drapeau
tricolore continue à flotter comme ce
sera bientôt le cas dans toutes les
classes et toutes les écoles de france
grâce à l'amendement que j'ai fait
adopter à l'assemblée nationale alors
oui ensemble nous devons dire à ceux qui
veulent rejoindre notre nation à ceux
qui veulent rejoindre notre continent
que ce n'est pas à la france pas plus
qu'à l'europe de s'adapter à leur
culture d'origine mais que c'est à eux
de s'assimiler à notre culture nous
disons nous disons mes amis dans le même
esprit que ce n'est pas notre pays ce
n'est pas à la france de se soumettre à
l'ismer à l'islam politique conquérant
et violent mais c'est ta l'islam de
respecter les lois de la république
alors mes amis alors mes amis
ces combats essentiels sont devant nous
nous devons préserver l'héritage de ceux
qui nous ont précédés soyons fidèles au
message de ces hommes et de ces femmes
qui ont fait l'histoire de france
soyons fidèle à l'héritage du général de
gaulle de georges pompidou de valéry
giscard d'estaing de jacques chirac de
nicolas sarkozy
et je le dis aussi et je le dis aussi
parce que pour moi c'est une question de
fidélité et de dignité parce qu'il a été
courageux soyons fidèles au beau projet
qu'avait apporté françois fillon en 2017
soyons fidèles pour conclure au message
de philippe seguin lorsqu'ils défendent
d une europe moins naïve avec charles
pasqua
oui oui nous voulons l'europe mais
disait-il nous voulons l'europe debout
parce que ces deux bouts koné cris
l'histoire le 26 mai mes amis nous
allons réécrire
nous allons écrire cette belle page de
l'histoire de france
debout avec vous alors oui
battez vous mobilisez vous fait gagner
avec laurent wauquiez françois-xavier
bellamy
[Applaudissements]
chers amis merci de réserver maintenant
un tonnerre d'applaudissements à notre
tête de liste aux élections européennes
du 26 mai prochain
françois-xavier bellamy
[Musique]
chers amis quel immense joie d'être avec
vous ce soir ici au cannet et de vous
retrouver tous et je voudrais commencer
en vous disant de tout coeur en disant à
chacun d'entre vous un immense merci
pour votre présence ce soir
jean-eric l'on dit le fait de vous voir
si nombreux et déjà en tant que tel un
très grand signe d'espoir et c'est le
fait que vous soyez là qui porte la
dynamique qui nous conduit aujourd'hui
dans cette campagne c'est votre présence
partout en france partout où nous allons
avec laurent avec tous nos colistiers
avec agnès et arnaud c'est votre
présence partout votre confiance et
votre soutien qui nous porte qui nous
pousse à tout donner pour vous avec vous
pendant tous les jours qui viennent et
qui nous séparent du 26 mai merci
infiniment
michel de nous accueillir chez vous
c'est une joie d'être ici dans le sud
dans ce département dans cette ville où
notre famille politique a vécu de si
grands moments où elle vivra encore j'en
suis sûr comme c'est le cas encore ce
soir tant de beaux moments encore grâce
au travail que vous faites
merci eric de ton accueil dans cette
fédération que tu portes dans ce
département où nous savons à quel point
être de droite n'est pas une honte
être de droite ne suppose pas qu'on
s'excuse de ce qu'on pense
et tu portes aux cette voie que nous
venons de t'entendre dire encore devant
nous ce soir
je voudrais te dire cher eric à quel
point j'ai été touché de ta confiance
dans cette élection pour laquelle je
m'avance devant vous ce soir de fête
c'est une chance pour moi que nous
soyons si nombreux mais c'est aussi une
chance qui m'engagent esbaudir qui
m'impressionne est presque qui
m'intimide comme l'a dit jean tout à
l'heure
comme l'a dit jean tout à l'heure c'est
vrai je n'avais rien demandé mais pour
une raison très simple c'est que je ne
pensais pas mérité quoi que ce soit
et de fait je n'ai pas mérité la
confiance qui m'a été faite cette
confiance est un pari c'est un pari fou
c'est un pari incroyable j'espère être à
la hauteur de ce pari mais ce pari nous
le devons seulement à laurent wauquiez
je voudrais dire à quel point je sais
parfaitement que d'autres auraient sans
doute lui bien plus de compétences bien
plus d'expérience bien plus de
légitimité que moi pour porter ce grand
défi j'ai été frappée que dans une vie
politique si souvent rongé par
l'individualisme par les égoïsmes
solitaire j'ai été l'objet de la
confiance de ceux qui auraient pu
prétendre à exercer aujourd'hui cette
responsabilité et je voudrais dire en
particulier à quel point j'ai été touché
de ta bienveillance cher jean chaire
jean leonetti toi qui depuis le début
m'a montré à quel point cet engagement
qui est le tien était celui qui partage
et qui fait partager les valeurs plutôt
qu'elle ne sépare de fait peut-être
certains ont pu douter certains ont pu
se demander si c'était le meilleur choix
je voudrais leur dire très simplement
que je ne leur en veux pas parce que je
me suis posé les mêmes questions est ce
qui compte c'est que nous soyons
ensemble se soient rassemblés
il n'y a pas contrairement à ce que
disent certains il n'y a pas d'effet
bellamy il y a seulement un effet
famille enfin réunis il y a seulement un
effet famille enfin réunis autour d'une
clarté retrouver autour de conviction
partagée autour d'un projet fort et
clair et c'est cela qui nous porte et
j'ai eu la chance d'être investi depuis
le début de cette campagne avec agnès
evren avec arnaud danjean avec lesquels
nous avons partagé les premiers moments
difficiles parfois de cette campagne
européenne et qui m'ont beaucoup appris
et qui m'ont beaucoup enseigné par nos
parlementaires européens sortants
spécialiste reconnu en europe des
questions si importante de lutte contre
le terrorisme de défense de sécurité et
qui m'a beaucoup enseigné depuis le
début ce qui pouvait permettre d'acheter
et au mieux notre projet et notre parole
pour pouvoir être le plus efficace
demain dans l'action que nous porterons
j'ai été rejoint depuis nous avons été
rejoints par tant de colistiers qui
apporte de toute la france leur
compétence leur expérience leur regard
sur notre europe
c'est cela qui fait la force d'une
équipe politique je n'ai jamais été ma
chronique parce que je n'ai jamais cru
que le nouveau monde et est forcément
meilleur que l'ancien
et pour ma part je crois au contraire
que ce qu'il y a de meilleur dans le
nouveau c'est toujours ce qui a été reçu
de l'ancien et que ce qui fait la force
de nos communautés humaines toutes nos
communautés humaines est d'abord de nos
familles comme de la moindre des équipes
municipales dans la plus petite des
communes comme de la plus grande des
aventures qui peut être est celle qui
nous lie aujourd'hui dans ce moment si
singulier de l'élection européenne ce
qui fait la force de toute communauté
humaine dans une entreprise comme dans
une association
c'est la complémentarité magnifique
entre ce qu'il faut de renouvellement
d'imagination et de créativité
mais ce qu'il faut aussi de compétences
de savoir faire qui se transmettent pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions être
efficace comprendre le monde qui vient
et relever ensemble les défis qui se
présentent à nous oui c'est ensemble que
nous sommes portés par ce bel élan
c'est ensemble que nous avançons et je
voudrais remercier tous ceux qui sont
ici tous les élus je ne vais pas tous
les citer tous nos élus qui portent avec
nous cette campagne comme ils portent
tous les jours la vie de notre
démocratie dans les tensions qui
traversent notre société
ils sont ceux par qui tient aujourd'hui
le pays qui est le nôtre et qui tient
par le terrain grâce à eux bien plus
qu'il ne tient par le haut je voudrais
remercier tous les élus les maires les
conseillers municipaux les conseillers
départementaux
les conseillers régionaux bien sûr nos
parlementaires qui incarne cette liberté
dont certains peut être ré préféré
qu'elle se taise
mais qui est bel et bien vivante grâce à
eux ils sont notre voix ils sont ceux
qui représentent la force dans notre
pays et nous pouvons les applaudir
ensemble ce soir
et puis je voudrais remercier bien sûr
tous mes colistiers tout ce qui
m'entoure dans cette campagne
ils sont nombreux ici ce soir je
voudrais citer simplement ceux qui sont
de ce département que vous avez entendu
s'exprimer et qui représente si bien
cette belle complémentarité
un ancien professeur un ancien étudiant
bernard et xavier merci d'être là pour
porter avec nous cette campagne se
défient le fait il faut que nous
puissions être à la hauteur de ce défi
qui se présente car ce soir nous sommes
heureux de nous retrouver bien sûr mais
nous avons tous dans le coeur une forme
de gravité qui a déjà été exprimé par
ceux qui m'ont précédé à cette tribune à
ce pupitre
si nous sommes ici ce soir c'est parce
que nous sommes tous animés d'une
question le pays dont nous héritons la
civilisation que nous avons en partage
va-t-elle encore durer dans le monde qui
se dessine pour nous encore transmettre
cette culture que nous avons reçues et
l'avoir durée pour nous voir nos
entreprises notre économie continuer de
prospérer pour nous reconstruire cette
société traversée de temps de fractures
et de tant de tension et je crois que
sur tous les grands défis qui attendent
notre avenir la réponse passe par
l'europe mais je crois que si toutes ces
questions se posent aujourd'hui c'est
aussi parce que l'europe n'a pas été à
la hauteur des défis de notre temps et
c'est parce que trop souvent l'europe
nous donne le sentiment de nous
fragiliser dans la mondialisation
au lieu de nous renforcer sur tous ces
grands défis sur le défi économique et
commerciale face à cette guerre qui se
joue souvent au dessus de nos têtes en
chine aux états unis
face à cette concurrence dont nous avons
l'impression de devenir de plus en plus
souvent les spectateurs résignés ou au
lieu d'en être les acteurs conquérant
face à la question migratoire questions
fondamentales bien sûr parce que
l'avenir de notre monde en dépend face
aux défis écologiques et
environnementales qui nous préoccupe
tous autour de cette mer méditerranée
qui connaît directement toutes les
pollutions qui viennent s'y déverser
fasse aussi évidemment à cette
inquiétude
culturel que nous éprouvons à cette
crise de la transmission qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons le sentiment
que nos enfants nos petits enfants
n'apprennent plus à l'école les éléments
les plus fondamentaux d'une culture et
d'un savoir qui pourront leur permettre
de trouver leur place dans notre société
face à tous ces grands défis la réponse
passe par l'europe nous en sommes
convaincus et nous sommes les héritiers
de ceux qui ont fait l'europe parce
qu'il savait que nous serons plus forts
ensemble que si nous restons isolé mais
face à tous ces grands défis nous savons
aussi très bien qu'aujourd'hui l'europe
que nous avons construite n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
et depuis le début de cette campagne
j'entends partout en france monter
l'inquiétude et l'angoissé de ceux qui
ont le sentiment que l'europe parfois
nous manque que parfois elle nous fait
défaut que parfois même elles nous
trahis
c'est le cri d'inquiétude de cet
agriculteur qui me dit j'ai toujours cru
à l'europe mais moi qui ne parvient pas
à m'en sortir alors que je me donne tant
de mal quand j'ai vu que l'europe
acceptait de faire rentrer sur notre
marché commun des centaines de milliers
de tonnes de soja ogm comme interdit de
cultiver
alors j'ai dit pour moi l'europe c'est
terminé eh bien à cet agriculteur là
comme à tant de chefs d'entreprise qui
vivent la même expérience comme à tant
de mer qui ont le sentiment que l'europe
sert plutôt à produire d'énormes
artificielle qu'apporter des projets
fort à tous ceux qui ont le sentiment
que l'europe n'est pas derrière eux pour
pouvoir les renforcer mais que parfois
trop souvent elle organise cette
concurrence déloyale que nous subissons
qu'elle organise notre impuissance à ce
cri d'inquiétude de cet agriculteur je
ne crois que je ne peux pas lui répondre
en lui disant qu'il est un populiste et
qu'il est un méchant mais je crois que
notre seule responsabilité c'est de
construire une europe de refonder une
europe dans laquelle plus jamais un
agriculteur ne puisse poser une telle
question de refonder une europe
dans laquelle plus jamais une telle
angoisse ne puisse s'exprimer
et oui c'est vrai parlons de ce défi
fondamental qu'est le défi économique et
le défit commercial
il faut enfin sortir de la naïveté
nous étions cet après midi grâce à jean
à sophia antipolis pour rencontrer des
chefs d'entreprise qui aujourd'hui
travaillent dans le monde et qui incarne
l'excellence de nos savoir faire
mais ces chefs d'entreprise nous
disaient qu'ils ont le sentiment que
nous sommes dans une forme de paralysie
que nous nous imposons à nous mêmes nous
avons construit ce marché unique qui est
une force extraordinaire qui pourraient
l'être en tous les cas mais qui est
aujourd'hui trop souvent réduit à n'être
qu'une proie qu une cible facile pour
ceux qui viennent y commercer alors qu
ils nous interdisent d'échanger avec
leur propre état le saviez vous chers
amis en europe 20% du pib est constitué
par les marchés publics et biens de
marchés publics sont ouverts à 95%
nous sommes les seuls au monde à donner
le signe de cette ouverture
car les marchés publics américains ne
sont couverts qu'à 30% les marchés
publics russes à 0% les marchés publics
chinois à 0%
comment est il possible qu'une
entreprise chinoise puisse venir faire
du profit en france alors qu'une
entreprise française jamais ne pourra
conquérir un marché public en chine
il est temps de sortir de la naïveté et
c'est ce que nous pouvons faire ensemble
j'étais il ya quelques jours de cela à
londres et je rencontrais nos amis
britanniques qui regardent aujourd'hui
avec un peu de regret cette aventure du
bric citant se disait en se disant qu'au
fond il y a d'abord un espoir qui
semblent s'évanouir pour eux qui est
celui d'obtenir d'autres partenaires
commerciaux d accord qui soit favorable
même les états unis finalement peuvent
contourner le marché britannique
aucun acteur international ne pourra
contourner le marché européen avec 60
millions d'habitants
n'importe quel grand acteur de ce monde
qui se dessine peut contourner nos
règles et nos lois mais avec ce marché
commun de 500 millions d'habitants nous
avons une force extraordinaire si nous
voulons bien faire de ce marché enfin
forces politiques si nous voulons bien
sortir de la naïveté si nous voulons
bien comme tu le disais ne pas en rester
seulement à une doctrine de la
concurrence qui a pour but de faire en
sorte que le consommateur puisse vivre
avec le produit le moins cher mais de
retrouver un cap industriel une
stratégie économique pour pouvoir fixer
de nouveaux une aventure pour l'avenir
une capacité d'investir nous redonner
une stratégie qui nous permettent de
transmettre à ceux qui nous suivront une
économie prospère ne pas en rester
seulement à une europe qui fait
appliquer des normes mais dessiner cette
europe qui peut devenir un acteur du
monde qui se dessine un acteur au
service de l' équilibre de ce monde et
notamment bien sûr de cet équilibre
écologique dont nous avons tellement
besoin car cette naïveté à laquelle nous
avons si longtemps cédé elle a produit
la catastrophe économique que nous
connaissons
elle a produit la catastrophe sociale
que nous avons vécu mais elle est aussi
directement responsable de ce problème
de ce grave problème de ce grave défi
climatique et écologique que nous avons
devant nous oui bien sûr nous sommes
préoccupés de ce défi climatique
il m'a parfois été reproché d'être
conservateur
je ne sais pas si ce mot peut suffire à
enfermer les grandes questions qui
attendent notre avenir mais une chose
est sûre je crois que nous le partageons
tous nous avons d'abord le désir de
transmettre à tous ceux qui nous
suivront notre culture notre
civilisation mais nous avons aussi le
désir de leur transmettre un monde qui
soit encore vivable et un homme qui soit
encore humain dans ce monde encore
vivable et pour cela bien sûr il faut
être à la hauteur de ce défi écologique
mais comment en être à la hauteur si on
ne s'attaque pas à la cause et où est la
cause du problème climatique sinon dans
cette mondialisation débridée
déséquilibré dans cette mondialisation
sans cap et sans but qui a créé ce monde
de flux perpétuel dont nous héritons
aujourd'hui parce que nous n'avons pas
su défendre notre industrie et notre
économie nous vivons aujourd'hui ce qui
est directement la cause de ce
déséquilibre que nous déplorons le
saviez vous gti il ya quelques jours sur
le port de pêche de lorient avec alain
cadec le président de la commission de
la pêche qui est un membre de notre
liste un spécialiste européen de ces
questions si importante pour la france
cette question de la pêche et avec alain
nous parlions avec des pêcheurs qui leur
disaient
ce que je dis depuis le début de cette
campagne c'est un exemple si parlant il
n'ya en europe quasiment plus aucune
capacité de filetage du poisson c'est à
dire de traitement du poisson quand vous
mangez le poisson sous forme de plats
préparés
en fait il a subi un processus de
traitement que l'on appelle le filetage
mais comme nous n'avons quasiment plus
aucune capacité de filetage en europe le
chemin qu'il a fait est généralement le
suivant un poisson qui est pêché au
large des côtes de l'ecosse et emmené
souvent en chine pour pouvoir être
traitées et ensuite il est ramené en
france pour pouvoir être consommés avant
d'arriver dans votre assiette il a fait
des milliers de kilomètres et ensuite on
explique aux salariés français qui a
besoin de sa voiture pour faire 10 km
pour aller travailler que c'est lui qui
responsables de la crise écologique et
que c'est lui qu'on va taxer jusqu'à ce
qu'il comprenne qu'il est un
absolue et bien moi je vous le dis ça
n'est pas raisonnable et si nous voulons
nous préoccuper de la crise écologique
il faut s'attaquer à la cause est la
cause c'est précisément cette
mondialisation débridée dans laquelle on
a cru trop longtemps que toute
l'industrie serait en chine et qu'en
europe on allait faire des services et
des loisirs
mais ça ne pouvait pas fonctionner ça ne
peut pas fonctionner il nous faut
réapprendre à produire ce que nous
consommons et c'est cet enjeu la majeur
qui est devant nous et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous proposons de créer
une barrière écologique une barrière
écologique qui fera que désormais sur le
marché européen
ceux qui voudront importé devront
respecter les mêmes règles que ceux qui
produisent en europe parce que nous
n'avons pas
parce que nous n'avons pas à nous
imposer cette concurrence déloyale que
nous organisons nous mêmes il faut
sortir de la naïveté il faut faire en
sorte qu enfin nous puissions contrôler
la manière dont ceux qui viennent en
europe importe et agissent en europe et
c'est tout le sens du travail
extraordinaire qu'a mené franck proust
ou au cours des dernières années
franck qui est parmi nous ce soir et qui
est le responsable de notre famille
politique au parlement européen franck
qui a fait voter qui a contribué à cette
avancée importante pour faire voter
enfin au parlement européen un mécanisme
de contrôle des investissements directs
étrangers sur le sol européen pour que
nous ne puissions pas voir petit à petit
nos actifs stratégiques captée par
d'autres acteurs une europe qui sortent
de la naïveté c'est je crois celle qu'il
nous faut refonder pour apporter notre
contribution à ce nouvel équilibre dans
le monde a besoin dans ce monde de
grandes puissances qui se dessine autour
de nous dans ce monde d'excès du bri
dans ce monde de démesure l'europe doit
apporter sa contribution à l'histoire de
notre époque
elle a si souvent contribué à l'histoire
du monde parfois pour le pied et souvent
pour le meilleur et bien il est temps
d'apporter encore le service que nous
avons à rendre à ce monde de demain en
constituant ce nouvel équilibre pour la
mondialisation que l'europe doit être
enfin ce poumon d'un nouvel équilibre
qui nous permettra de nouveau de
regarder l'avenir avec confiance et de
regarder avec fierté
l'excellence de nos savoir faire la
force de nos entreprises qui pourront de
nouveau retrouver cette compétitivité
que des réformes indispensables aussi
bien sûr en france lui auront redonné
ensemble redonner un équilibre à notre
monde c'est aussi bien sûr faire face à
ce grand défi que le défi migratoire
car ce défi migratoire n'est pas passée
et je m'étonne bien souvent que dans les
débats que j'ai pu vivre depuis le début
de cette campagne on met parfois
opposées que la crise migratoire était
fini
tiens donc nous dit on vous parlait
l'immigration met enfin en voyons la
crise migratoire c'était en 2015 c'est
terminé tout cela est bien mon cher ami
nous le savons très bien si nous voulons
sortir de la naïveté si nous voulons
bien ouvrir les yeux sur le monde de
demain
nous devons le dire avec force la crise
migratoire n'a pas encore
mais elle est largement devant nous
parce que la démographie du continent
africain qui est de l'autre rive de
cette méditerranée que nous avons en
partage la démographie du continent
africain va constituer l'occasion d'une
pression migratoire plus forte que
jamais si nous ne savons pas sortir de
l'impuissance dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui et si nous ne savons pas
sortir de cette impuissance
alors nous allons continuer de produire
du malheur à grande échelle malheur pour
nos sociétés qui sont déjà profondément
déstabilisé par une immigration que nous
n'avons pas su maîtriser et qui est
arrivé si nombreuses que nous ne savons
pas l'intégrer aujourd'hui je le dis
comme enseignant tant de jeunes
grandissent en france piégée dans la
spirale d'un communautarisme qui les
prive de se reconnaître dans une
communauté républicaine et nous n'avons
pas le droit de ne rien faire de ses
avertissements qui nous sont lancés par
tant de voix aujourd'hui jusqu'à celle
d'un ancien ministre de l'intérieur
socialiste qui quittant son ministère
nous a alertés aujourd'hui nous vivons
côte à côte
demain peut-être nous serons face à face
nous n'avons pas le droit de ne rien
faire d'une telle voie malheur pour nos
sociétés mais malheur tout autant pour
tous ces jeunes venus d'afrique auquel
des passeurs sans scrupules tendre le
miroir aux alouettes d'un eldorado
qu'ils ne trouveront pas en arrivant en
europe il ya tous ceux qui nous font de
grands discours de générosité à tous
ceux qui comme le président de la
république le faisait jusqu'à il y a peu
de temps à tous ceux qui vantent la
nécessité de l'ouverture et la volonté
de déconstruire les murs eh bien je
voudrais dire avec vous venez porte de
la chapelle
venez danser lieu de nos villes où
vivent aujourd'hui tant de ces jeunes
venus de tous les coins de l'afrique qui
viennent se retrouver dans cette impasse
que constitue l'europe pour eux ils
avaient cru trouver un lieu où ils
auraient leur place où il pourrait même
s'engager pour soutenir leurs familles
en fait ils se trouvent piégés parce que
nous n'avons pas de quoi les accueillir
et que la première règle de toute
humanité consisterait à leur dire cette
vérité qu'il faut maîtriser nos
frontières et que leur place est en
afrique pour développer leurs
pays et non pas chez nous en france
méprisé nos frontières c'est tout
l'enjeu de cette action européenne dont
laurent vous reparlera maîtrise de nos
frontières c'est tout l'enjeu de cette
politique de la double frontières que
nous voulons construire ensemble pour
qu'effectivement une action européenne
forte puisse être mené car nous croyons
que cette action européenne est
nécessaire et nous ne sommes pas de ceux
qui comme le rassemblement national ont
voté contre tout ce qui pouvait
renforcer l'europe face aux défis
migratoires mais nous croyons aussi à la
différence de monsieur macron que chacun
de nos états doit pouvoir garder la
maîtrise de sa politique migratoire et
c'est le sens de cette double frontières
que nous défendons ensemble et puis
enfin bien sûr tout le défi qui est
devant nous c'est celui de cette
civilisation qui cherchent à se
transmettre et qui cherche en elle-même
des raisons de se transmettre
si nous devons faire en sorte que ce
défi économique et commerciale soit
relevé si nous devons faire en sorte de
maîtriser nos frontières fait d'abord
parce que nous croyons que nous sommes
les héritiers d'une histoire qui mérite
d'être continuer et je voudrais
m'arrêter avec vous un bref instant sur
ce sujet qui me paraît essentiel ce qui
fait la force des grandes puissances que
nous regardons dans le monde avec
parfois un peu d'inquiétude
ce n'est pas seulement la vitalité de
leur économie ce n'est pas seulement
l'efficacité de leur industrie
ce n'est pas seulement la force de leurs
de leurs armées respectives
mais c'est d'abord la conscience très
fortes qu'elles ont ces grandes
puissances de porter une culture une
civilisation et d'agir au nom de quelque
chose qui les précèdent et qui les
dépasse et c'est sans doute d'abord cela
que nous avons perdu jean tu l'as dit
paul valéry nous le disaient les
civilisations sont mortelles mais aucune
civilisation ne meurent parce qu'elle a
été attaquée et nous serions bien
inconscient de nous faire croire à nos
même que ce sont nos adversaires qui
nous menacent aujourd'hui toutes
civilisations meurent d'abord de cet
oublié elle même
et c'est peut-être
et c'est peut-être bien sûr ce qui est
arrivé à l'europe si nous avons été
déshérités en effet c'est d'abord parce
que nous nous sommes refusés à nous même
de transmettre cette civilisation que
nous avions en partage c'est peut-être
parce que nous avons été incapables de
nommer cette civilisation qui nous porte
de dire quelle est notre culture nous
avons élu un candidat à la présidence de
la république qui nous avait expliqué
qu'il n'y a pas de culture française et
je crois que mes ne disons pas trop de
mal de lui il n'était pas en cela un
problème mais un symptôme le symptôme
d'un oubli dont il n'était pas le seul
acteur dont il n'est pas le seul auteur
d'un oubli qui dure depuis trop
longtemps depuis plusieurs décennies
comment se fait-il que nous ayons pu en
venir à croire qu'il n'ya pas de culture
française alors que des étrangers du
monde entier viennent en touristes
découvrir notre culture nous sommes le
premier pays touristique au monde celui
que le monde entier vient admirer celui
que le monde entier vient découvrir
parce que le monde entier sait qu'il y a
une culture française et qu'elle mérite
d'être goûter et qu'elle mérite d'être
admiré et dire cela ne doit pas dire
cela ne doit pas nous faire sentir
orgueilleux de ce que nous n'avons pas
produit nous mêmes nous sommes d'abord
des héritiers dire cela c'est seulement
nous sentir obligé nous sentir les
obligés de ceux qui nous ont précédés et
qui nous ont légué cette histoire
magnifique
monsieur macron n'était pas le premier à
commettre cet oubli comment se fait-il
que la france est était d'ailleurs aux
avant postes lorsqu'ils y a quelques
années dans ce débat un peu absurde
nous avons refusé d'inscrire dans les
traités fondateurs de l'union européenne
la mention de nos racines car l'europe
ce n'est pas d'abord un projet
l'europe ce n'est pas d'abord des prêtés
l'europe ce n'est pas d'abord une
commission des comités l'europe c'est
d'abord une histoire c'est d'abord un
élan c'est d'abord un héritage c'est
vous l'avez rappelé ce petit miracle
fragile de la naissance de la raison qui
commencent à poindre au cinquième siècle
grecque dans les cités au bord de la
méditerranée qui allait peu à peu porté
à tout le monde méditerranéen le sens de
ce qu'est la liberté lorsque par les
forts de cette raison entrer en dialogue
nous construisons cette expérience
magnifique qui s'appelle une démocratie
pour parler ensemble de l'avenir que
nous voulons plutôt que de le subir
l'europe c'est le sens de l'égalité de
tous devant la respublica devant la
chose commune le sens de cette égalité
qui mûrit dans l' empire romain et qui
se transmet par lui à tout le monde
latin et l'europe c'est aussi évidemment
et pourquoi ne pas le dire
pourquoi avons nous tant tardé à le
nommer l'europe c'est le moment de cette
prise de conscience de la dignité
humaine qui s'opère progressivement à
travers la tradition chrétienne la
tradition judéo chrétienne qui marquent
notre continent
dire cela ce n'est pas seulement se
tourner avec nostalgie vers un passé
révolu
ce matin une ministre du gouvernement
disait sur une chaîne de télévision
qu'en parlant de ses racines
nous nous comportions comme des
nostalgiques romantique et passéiste et
bien nous voulons dire à madame de
montchalin que si pour elle nommé nos
racines que si pour elle reconnaître
notre histoire que si pour elle se
tourner vers cet héritage que si pour
elle
vouloir transmettre cette culture si
pour elle tout cela c'est être passéiste
nous lui laissons le privilège de cette
triste considération car nous savons les
premiers qu'il n'y aura pas d'avenir
pour notre pays si nous ne savons pas
nommé de nouveau nos racines si nous ne
savons pas dire qui nous sommes
il n'y a pas d'avenir pour notre société
si nous sommes incapables de dire la
force de ce qui nous lie la force de ce
qui nous relie la force de ce qui fait
ce bien commun que nous avons en partage
et dans lequel chacun d'entre nous peut
se reconnaître français et européens à
la fois oui bien sûr
oui bien sûr face à tous les grands
défis qui menacent nos sociétés il faut
des réponses techniques il faut des
réponses pratiques
oui bien sûr l'europe dont nos élites on
a permis de construire la paix et cette
paix est aujourd'hui menacé bien sûr
nous n'allons pas entrer en guerre
demain contre l'allemagne
mais la guerre ce n'est pas seulement
cela la guerre c'est aussi ce qui frappe
durement notre pays déjà à travers le
terrorisme islamiste qui traversent nos
sociétés et qui a touché si durement à
nice qui a touché si durement dans notre
pays au cours des dernières années la
guerre et la violence c'est ce à quoi
l'europe doit aujourd'hui réagir fille
elle veut rester elle même est bien face
à ce terrorisme islamiste il faut des
réponses policières bien sûr et nous
avons au coeur de notre projet cet
engagement de pouvoir renforcer une
coopération européenne sur cette
dimension policière il faut des réponses
judiciaires bien sûr et nous avons au
coeur de notre projet ce qu'il faut de
propositions pour conforter une réponse
judiciaire européenne face aux défis
terroristes mais à la fin nous ne
gagnerons la guerre contre le terrorisme
islamiste
nous ne gagnerons la guerre contre la
gangrène de l'islam radical que si nous
savons veut dire qui nous sommes
car cet islam radical avec toute sa
violence et sa brutalité est venu
remplir le vide que nous avions
nous-mêmes l'essai et c'est la raison
pour laquelle et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce n'est pas être passéiste que
de se tourner vers cette histoire qui
nous a fait ce n'est pas être passéiste
que de reconnaître la valeur des biens
que nous avons dans nos mains au
contraire c'est reconnaître que ces
biens sont notre vie notre vie
d'aujourd'hui et notre vie de demain
je crois que c'est ce que nous avons
tous ressenti tous lorsque nous avons vu
il y a quelques jours dans ce moment
éprouvant et pourtant singulièrement
émouvant lorsque nous avons vu il y a
quelques jours brûlé le toit de la
cathédrale de notre dame de paris
nous avons tous sentis en même temps que
nous étions atteint touché dans nos
coeurs dans nos esprits dans nos tripes
presque retourné
ce que nous étions en train de voir et
nous avons senti alors que c'était
quelque chose de nous mêmes qui étaient
en train de brûler j'ai eu l'occasion
cher xavier d'échangés il y a quelques
jours avec le général qui commande la
brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de paris
pour aller lui dire notre infinie
reconnaissance et à travers lui à tous
les hommes qu'il commandait ce soir là
pour l'acte incroyable qu'ils avaient
fait en préservant pour nous et pour
tous ceux qui nous suivront cette
cathédrale inestimable et je crois oui
cher xavier que à travers l'engagement
qui est le tien à travers l'engagement
qui est celui de tous ceux qui comme toi
s'engage pour notre sécurité se joue
quelque chose de fondamental pour la vie
d'une société qui est le sens de cette
solidarité qui nous lie
je le dis avec un peu de gravité parce
que c'est cela que l'europe peut être
aujourd'hui menace la règle d'une
directive et d'une norme totalement
absurde est en train de menacer
directement le principe même du
volontariat des sapeurs-pompiers de ces
sapeurs pompiers qui veille toute la
nuit sur notre sécurité qui veille à la
fin de leur journée de travail pour que
bénévolement par leur engagement ils
puissent apporter cette proximité des
secours que notre modèle de sécurité
civile apporte aujourd'hui à chaque
français eh bien c'est ce modèle qui est
aujourd'hui menacée et nous nous
battrons je te le dis avec toi cher
xavier pour défendre ce modèle de
sécurité pour défendre ce modèle qui est
d'abord un modèle de solidarité et de
civilisation le général qui commandait
la brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de paris
avec lui nous méditions sur cette
expérience qui pardonnez moi de revenir
à mon tropisme professionnels et presque
l'occasion d'une méditation
philosophique
lorsque la cathédrale brûlés le choix a
été fait d'envoyer des hommes monter
dans les tours de cette cathédrale pour
tenter d'arrêter lé incendie qui
menaçait d'atteindre les poutres qui
supportaient les cloches s'il incendies
les avaient touchés
ces cloches se seraient effondrés et les
tours se serait écroulé avec elle
le choix a été fait d'envoyer des hommes
dans ces tours comme d'autres pompiers
dans les tours du 11 septembre aux états
unis
mais cette fois il n'y avait pas de vie
humaine en jeu et pourtant ces hommes
sont montés et ils ont risqué leur vie
ils ont risqué leur vie alors qu'il n'y
avait pas de vie humaine en jeu ils ont
fait infiniment plus que leur devoir
aucun d'entre eux me disait le général
n'a manqué à l'appel ils sont tous
montés en sachant qu'à tout instant ces
tours pouvait s'écrouler
ils sont montés pour aller sauver non
pas des vies mais des pierres parce que
ces pierres sont vivantes
parce que ces pierres sont notre vie et
que nous soyons croyants ou non que nous
soyons croyants ou non le pouvons nous
reconnaître nous pouvons nous
reconnaître dans ce livre magnifique qui
fait je le crois profondément la
condition de notre avenir le choix
qu'ont fait ces hommes n'était pas un
choix passéiste ça n'était pas un choix
nostalgique
ça n'était pas le choix d'un romantisme
suranné c'était le choix de la
responsabilité absolue
il faut restaurer notre dame de paris
mais il faut bien sûr aussi restaurer ce
lien qui nous attachent les uns aux
autres ce lien qui nous unit et qui est
la condition pour que nous puissions
nous reconnaître dans un avenir commun
c'est d'ici qu'est partie cette culture
extraordinaire des rives de la
méditerranée et de ses îles de lérins
faire david
d'où partent aujourd'hui encore temps
aventure magnifique c'est d'ici qu'est
partie cette culture et cette
civilisation et c'est d'ici sans aucun
doute qu'il faut nous attacher à la
refonder car nous ne serons plus une
société ne seront plus une nation si
nous ne savons pas dire qui nous sommes
et sims ou si nous ne savons pas quel
est ce lien qui nous unit
nous n'avons aucune chance de vaincre
l'islam radical si nous ne savons pas de
nouveau donné à tous les jeunes qui
grandissent en france quelque chose a
aimé et qui s'appelle la france et qui
s'appelle l'europe et qui s'appelle cet
héritage
nous n'avons aucune chance
nous n'avons aucune chance de sortir de
ce piège qui est la france archipel
décrite par jérôme fourquet si nous ne
savons pas que nous ne sommes pas qu'une
addition de communauté qui s'ignorent
les unes les autres mais que nous sommes
une communauté réunie par cet héritage
commun qui nous vient d'une histoire
ancienne mais qui est notre présent
notre être d'aujourd'hui et qui est ce
par quoi nous pouvons nous projeter dans
l'avenir et ce par quoi nous pouvons
faire confiance à notre possibilité de
rio n'est encore longtemps dans l'avenir
et dans le monde
alors oui c'est vrai c'est ici sans
doute c'est ce soir qu'il faut dire
notre souhait de refonder l'europe pour
pouvoir rétablir la france et comme
c'est d'ici qu'est partie cette
civilisation magnifique pour irriguer
tout le monde de la grèce antique et
tout le monde de l'empiré romain
tout ce monde de la chrétienté de
l'héritage judéo-chrétien tout ce monde
des lumières tout ce monde de la
modernité critique qui fait de nous ce
que nous sommes
parce que c'est d'ici qu'est partie
cette aventure magnifique s'est dit si
possible doit partir sa refondation
nécessaire
carphi nous ne savons pas faire ce choix
alors nous sortirons de l'histoire mais
si nous savons faire ce choix nous avons
toutes les raisons d'y croire encore
nous avons toutes les raisons de croire
encore dans cet avenir qui est devant
nous de faire confiance à la force de
nos entreprises à l'excellence de nos
savoir-faire à l'énergie de tous ceux
qui partout en france travaillent encore
malgré toutes les difficultés malgré le
découragement malgré la peine malgré les
règles qui viennent d'en haut et qui
semble inhibé asphyxié l'action ce qui
aujourd'hui porte et font vivre la
france et font vivre l'europe ont
largement de quoi donner à cette france
et à cette europe un avenir radieux
rayonnant un avenir plein d'espoir et
c'est ce qui est en jeu dans la promesse
qui nous associe ce soir nous voulons
refonder l'europe pour pouvoir rétablir
la france alors pour pouvoir relever ce
défi magnifique nous avons besoin de
vous je vous le disais tout à l'heure je
ne suis que le porte-voix humblement et
modestement de cette équipe magnifique
avec laquelle nous portons ce défi
derrière toi laurent derrière toute
notre famille politique je voudrais être
votre voix mais j'ai besoin pour cela
que vous soyez aussi nos voix il nous
reste 24 jours
vingt-quatre jours 24 jours pour
convaincre 24 jours pour ramener à nous
tous ceux qui doutent
tous ceux qui ont été déçus tous ceux
qui ont été déçus par la politique et
disons le aussi tous ceux qui ont été
déçus parfois par notre famille
politique
vingt-quatre jours pour leur dire qu'il
est temps d'y croire encore que nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix que d'y croire
encore que de faire ce pari fou de
l'espoir parce que nous avons toutes les
ressources pour espérer pour espérer
encore longtemps pour agir et pour
rayonner mais qu'il est temps maintenant
de faire les choix nécessaires pour être
à la hauteur du défi qui se présente à
nous aujourd'hui le 26 mai il faut que
nous puissions faire ce choix
définir ce cap clair pour pouvoir
dessiner l'avenir de cette europe que
nous voulons au service de notre france
le 26 mai cette victoire qui se dessine
c'est vous qui leur est conquise ce sera
votre victoire nous la devons à notre
pays de la devons à notre europe
vive la france et vive l'europe merci
infiniment
[Applaudissements]
chers amis accueillons à présent le
président des républicains
une immense ovation pour laurent
wauquiez
[Musique]
maintenant vous savez maintenant vous
savez pourquoi j'ai voulu que
françois-xavier bellamy puisse porter
nos couleurs ici mes amis ici c'est la
maison
ici c'est la maison
ici c'est la maison des républicains ici
dans les alpes maritimes
c'est la maison de notre famille
politique il n'ya pas d'autres
départements où les racines des
républicains sont plus profondes il n'y
a pas d'autres non il n'y a pas d'autres
départements dans lesquels nous avons
autant de militants il n'y a pas
d'autres départements dans lesquels nous
avons autant d'élus il n'y a pas
d'autres départements qui nous ait
soutenus du cette façon aussi
indéfectible tout le temps ne l'oublions
pas et c'est moi qui le dis ici c'est la
maison mais bien sûr que celui qui vient
d'auvergne rhône alpes est indigné à
l'idée que ce soit la première
fédération notre famille politique
mais oui c'est bien la première
fédération notre famille politique et je
vous en suis infiniment reconnaissant
parce que ici même dans les moments les
plus difficiles
j'ai toujours trouvé un point d'appui
ici je n'oublie pas quand je me suis
lancé dans cette campagne pour refonder
notre famille que vous m'avez accueilli
avec chaleur avec espoir et avec
enthousiasme et que vous m'avez dit à ce
moment là je m'en souviens encore dans
cette belle salle vous étiez vous aussi
tous présents on va reconstruire et on
sera à vos côtés et on va le faire et on
n'aura de cesse que d'être allé jusqu'au
bout de nos idées comme c'est sûr entrer
dans cette salle et que vous ai vu aussi
nombreux vous n'imaginez pas ce que ça
représente pour moi ce que ça représente
pour chacun d'entre nous comme soutien
de votre part parce que c'est une façon
très simple mais si forte de nous dire
ne lâchez pas
eh bien je veux bien que vous comprenez
que je ne le ferai jamais et je ne
lâcherai pas je ne le ferai pas un pas
uniquement parce que je veux rebâtir
notre famille je ne lâcherai pas pas
uniquement parce que je suis convaincu
qu'il faut que nous puissions revenir
aux responsabilités en ayant tiré les
leçons des erreurs que nous avons pu
commettre par le passé je ne lâcherai
pas uniquement pour cela je ne lâcherai
pas parce que je suis convaincu que nous
avons une mission que nous avons une
responsabilité à l'égard de notre pays
que nous avons un chemin que nous devons
tracer et au bout duquel nous ne sommes
pas encore allés et quand je rentre dans
cette salle aux côtés de françois xavier
aux côtés d'eric aux côtés de michel aux
côtés de gens que je retrouve tous les
amis qui sont ici il ya une chose qui me
marque
ne vous y trompez pas il n'y a aucune
autre famille politique qui dans cette
campagne des européennes est capable de
faire ce que nous faisons ce soir depuis
que nous sommes entrés en campagne il y
a seule liste qui a bousculé les
pronostics
il y a une seule liste qui semaine après
semaine jour après jour et monte petit à
petit a imposé petit à petit sa
dynamique
il y a une seule liste kane dynamique
dans cette campagne des européennes
c'est la liste des républicains c'est la
liste de l'union de la droite et du
centre
vous pouvez en être fier parce que c'est
le résultat de votre travail
mais si nous allons un peu au delà c'est
plus que cela
je suis convaincu que nos compatriotes
ne veulent pas d'une chose ils ne
veulent pas qu'on leur confie ce que
leur voix ils ne veulent pas qu'on
décide à leur place comme on le fait
depuis si longtemps dans notre pays ils
en ont assez qu'on leur explique ce
qu'on a le droit de penser ce qu'on n'a
pas le droit de dire il ne supporte plus
que la démocratie en france se résume à
d'un côté les populistes et de l'autre
les progressistes les français veulent
retrouver le choix ils ne veulent pas
être enfermé à nouveau dans cette
réédition funeste du second tour de la
présidentielle les français ne veulent
pas se retrouver pris entre d'un côté le
chaos de marine le pen et de l'autre la
déception des manuels
macron et si jamais les choses sont en
train de bouger du côté de la liste des
républicains c'est parce que les
français ont compris que le seul endroit
où il pouvait y avoir un choix qu'il
retrouve ses du côté des républicains
la démocratie c'est le choix et nous ne
nous laisserons pas confisquer ce choix
parce que des deux côtés
ce sont deux impasses et la réalité
d'ailleurs c'est qu'il se soutiennent
l'un et l'autre chacun d'une part et de
l'autre du précipice au dessus duquel
ils font danser notre démocratie
vous avez d'un côté marine le pen mais
marine le pen est une impasse parce que
ce que propose marine le pen pour
l'europe c'est la déconstruction de
l'europe ce que propose marine le pen
c'est de mettre à bas tout ce que nos
prédécesseurs compte édifier ce qu'elle
propose c'est de sortir de l'union
européenne ce qu'elle propose c'est de
sortir de l'euro dans un pays qui a
autant de dettes dans un pays qui a
autant de déficit mais sortir de l'euro
certains qui sont ici s'en souviennent
cela veut dire une seule chose
cela veut dire une dévaluation monétaire
cela veut dire qu'un jour vous vous
réveillez que votre patrimoine a fondu
et que votre pouvoir d'achat a été
réduit ce que propose marine le pen
c'est la déconstruction de l'europe
et si je la combat de toutes mes forces
dans cette élection européenne
c'est parce que je suis convaincu que
pour la france ce serait une sortie de
l'histoire
je ne veux pas de cela pour la france je
ne veux pas de ce destin et comment ne
pas le comprendre quand il suffit
aujourd'hui de regarder de l'autre côté
de la manche pour voir la catastrophe et
le chaos qu'installe de bréxent it ce
que propose marine le pen c'est une
impasse mais ce que propose emmanuel
macron de l'autre côté c'est tout autant
une impasse parce que comme
françois-xavier l'a très bien dit de
l'autre côté emmanuel macron n'a pas
compris que nous croyons dans l'europe
mais nous voulons remettre l'europe dans
le bon chemin
nous croyons dans l'europe
mais nous sommes convaincus que l'europe
petit à petit s'est écarté de ce
qu'était sa mission initiale qu elle l
europe des manuels macron mais c'est
toujours plus de l'europe qui ne marche
pas emmanuel macron propose d'étendre
encore l'élargissement comme s'il n'y
avait pas suffisamment de pays
différents qui sont autour de la table
et comme si cela n'avait pas dit abouti
à affaiblir durablement la construction
européenne dans chacun de ses discours
emmanuel macron propose toujours plus de
bureaucratie bruxelloise
quand vous faites l'addition il a
proposé jusqu'à 15 agences
supplémentaires et la création de quatre
impôts supplémentaires à bruxelles c'est
toute l'europe dont nous ne voulons pas
il n'a pas compris qu'il fallait quoi
qu'il fallait refonder l'europe est le
plus grave dans tout cela c'est qu'il
isole petit à petit la france
soyons honnête quand il a été élu il ya
eu un élan d'intérêt des autres pays
européens
et d'ailleurs nous pousse nous nous
sommes dit et s'il faisait le travail
et puis nos partenaires européens l'ont
vu faire et ils ont compris assez
rapidement quelque chose et je me
souviens d'une conversation que j'ai eue
à l'époque avec angela merkel qui me
disaient nous on n'écoute pas les
discours des présidents de la république
on regarde leur premier budget est bien
ce que nos partenaires européens ont
compris c'est quoi ce qu'ils ont compris
c'est que le président parlait il espère
un président qui réformerait et ils ont
compris que le président parlait et
qu'il se contentait de parler et l'
enthousiasme a laissé place à la
déception
et nous nous sommes aliéné nos
partenaires italiens auxquels nous avons
fait la leçon et nous nous sommes aliéné
les partenaires d'europe centrale
auxquels nous avons fait la leçon en
leur expliquant qu'ils avaient tort de
vouloir arrêter les vagues d'immigration
et nous nous sommes aliéné nos
partenaires scandinave auquel nous avons
fait la leçon et nous ont répondu
mais qui êtes vous vous qui êtes le
dernier de la classe et qui avait le
pire déficit budgétaire de toute la zone
euro et vous voulez donner des leçons
aux autres mais commencez par faire des
économies sur la dépense publique
vous qui avait été incapable en deux ans
de diminuer votre dette seul pays au
sein de la zone euro à ne pas avoir été
capable de réduire sa dette
ne vous y trompez pas quand un pays ne
fait pas d'économies sur sa dépense
publique
à l'arrivée d'une manière ou d'une autre
il le prend dans votre poche
les cadeaux d'aujourd'hui seront les
impôts de demain est une des garanties
que nous nous apportons c'est qu'avec
notre liste des républicains de l'union
de la droite et du centre
nous nous inscrivons dans le plus grand
groupe parlementaire du parlement
européen et ça c'est une fierté pour
chacun d'entre vous nous sommes à
l'intérieur de la grande tradition du
parti populaire européen
la grande tradition du gaullisme et de
la démocratie chrétienne c'est notre
famille politique qui a édifié l'europe
quand les français votent pour notre
liste ils votent pour une voix forte de
la france à l'échelle de bruxelles
quand ils votent pour en marche ils
votent pour une proposition dans
laquelle le président de la république
propose d'isoler les députés français
dans un tout petit groupe qui sera un
des tous plus petit groupe à l'échelle
du parlement européen et bien moi quand
on est la france je veux que l'on soit
en première division
je ne veux pas que l'on condamne la voix
de la france au silence
alors oui nous avons une immense
responsabilité refonder l'europe pour
établir la france et pour mener cette
refondation
j'ai voulu un nouveau souffle et je
remercie ceux qui m'ont accompagné dans
ce choix
je voudrais d'ailleurs rendre hommage à
jean parce que l'un des premiers avec
lequel j'ai changé dessus ces gens et à
des premiers à m'avoir encouragé à me
dire laurent fait le choix du
renouvellement fait le choix d'une
nouvelle génération sétois jean avec une
démarche qui t'honore toi qui a été un
si bon ministre des affaires européennes
et qui a si bien des formules notre
famille politique
merci merci à toi et pour cette
refondation
j'ai souhaité que ce soit françois
xavier qui porte nos couleurs avec ce
trio qui est à ses côtés
agnès est vrai mme arnaud danjean cette
jeune génération ses talents qu'on doit
faire monter quand on s'occupe d'une
famille politique il faut faire monter
les meilleurs il ne faut pas étouffer
les talents c'est une erreur que nous
avons si souvent fait par le passé et je
vais vous dire ce que j'ai aimé et ce
que j'aime dans ce qui porte tous
ensemble et dans ce que porte françois
xavier
d'abord la première chose c'est une
droite de valeur vous l'avez vu qu'il ne
s'excuse pas de ses idées on ne
reconstruira jamais notre famille
politique
si nous continuons à baisser le regard
et à marcher à l'ombre
jamais cela nous a réussi la droite
réussit quand elle porte la fierté et la
dignité de ses valeurs et de ses
convictions
et la deuxième chose c'est que ça
redonne un peu de hauteur
vous savez quand il ya eu ce débat
france télévisions et que chacun des
candidats devaient sortir un objet
symbolique de ce qu'il pensait de
l'europe et au fur et à mesure que
chacune des têtes de lit sortait un
objet je me disais mais comment la
politique at elle pu tomber aussi bas
le représentant du rassemblement
national sortait une passoire rouge
le rassemblement de je ne sais même plus
quelle liste avait sorti une paire de
menottes sur lequel il avait mis des
autocollants jaunes
la représentante de la liste en marche
avait sorti une petite boîte de piment
d'espelette j'adore le piment
d'espelette mais enfin honnêtement pour
incarner sa vision de l'europe peut-être
qu'il y avait autre chose à faire et à
chaque marche on descendait un peu plus
bas et françois-xavier lui nous a
heureusement redonner notre honneur lui
il a sorti un livre et quels livres 7 et
l'iliade d'homère
merci françois xavier de nous tirer vers
le haut et ceux dont j'ai toujours été
convaincu
c'est qu'on peut affirmer ses
convictions tout en rassemblant on peut
affirmer ses convictions tout en
rayonnant certains croient qu'il faut
qu'on renonce à ce que nous sommes pour
pouvoir tendre la main
certains croient que quand on défend ses
idées et ses valeurs on se rétrécit et
bien moi je crois tout l'inversé
je crois que quand on défend ses idées
quand on les explique au grand jour
c'est à ce moment là que l'on peut
rassembler regardez l'image aujourd'hui
de notre famille politique
ils sont tous là tout le monde est
présent
le premier auquel je veux rendre hommage
c'est eric vous le savez dans une
démarche de reconstruction c'est très
difficile c'est une démarche qui est
ardue et j'ai besoin de compter sur des
personnes qui sont là quand les sondages
sont hauts comme sur des personnes qui
sont là quand les sondages sont bas eric
il est toujours avec moi je n'ai jamais
besoin de me retourner
je sais que je peux compter sur sa
confiance son engagement et sa
détermination merci à toi eric merci il
y à michel ici quand nous avons lancé ce
ciment semble michel nous avons
longuement parlé tous les deux et
j'apprécie chez toi cette droiture et
cette loyauté indéfectible qui vient
puiser dans l'histoire de ta famille tu
de ta famille personnelle merci miss m
depuis que nous avons cheminé ensemble
tu as toujours été là et je suis très
reconnaissant aussi de ta présence
encore une fois ici il y à tous ceux qui
sont venus charles ange qui veille sur
votre département
il y à nos parlementaires j'espère
n'oublier personne henri-bernard colette
laurent
pierre eric dominique applaudissaient
les choses parce qu'il le mérite
il y à nos mères sébastien christian
louis david jérôme lionel jeanclaude
tous ceux qui sont ici et qui incarne
également notre fierté et j'aime quand
notre famille politique et rassembler
comme elle est ainsi et j'aime quand on
avance soudés comme on l'est est ainsi
pourquoi parce que dans cette campagne
nous sommes les seuls à parler d'europe
les autres parlent de bruxelles les
autres parlent de l'union européenne les
autres parlent d'une construction
administrative certains parlent de
souverainisme d'autres parlent de
fédéralisme mais qui parle de l'europe
nous sommes les seuls à parler de
l'europe parce que l'europe c'est autre
chose
l'europe c'est une âme l'europe c'est un
projet c'est un projet de civilisation
quand les pères fondateurs
au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale quand toute l'europe a été
détruite par la barbarie nazie décide
d'enclencher ce projet qui était fou à
l'époque de construire l'union des
nations
là où il n'y avait eu que de la haine et
des morts que font-ils sur ce drapeau
ils choisissent de mettre les étoiles de
la couronne de la vierge
il met les étoiles de la couronne de la
vierge élan doute un seul instant que ce
soit un projet de civilisation est
content il à ce moment comme question
françois xavier
c'est celle que tu as si bien résumé
est-ce que ce que nous sommes a encore
un avenir
ce qu'ils font à ce moment là c'est
qu'ils veulent montrer que la
reconstruction de l'europe n'aboutira
pas à la disparition de la voix de
l'europe ce qu'ils veulent montrer à ce
moment là c'est que ne dépendront pas
des américains et que l'europe va
reconstruire petit à petit son
indépendance et son autonomie
c'est ce chemin qu'ils construisent à ce
moment là et nous pourquoi êtes vous là
parce que vous vous posez tous la même
question est-ce qu'on a un avenir
ce que la voie de l'europe un avenir est
ce qu'on peut lui redonner un souffle
est-ce que nous sommes condamnés à
assister à ce que notre continent change
de nature christophe silencieusement
ou est-ce que nous pouvons redonner ce
souffle à la civilisation européenne
alors quand on vous interrogera en vous
demandant quelle europe
voulez-vous et bien l'europe que nous
voulons c'est celle qui inspirait
confiance parce qu'elle savait qui elle
était l'europe que nous voulons bernard
c'est l'europe puissance qui n'hésite
pas à défendre ses intérêts l'europe que
nous voulons c'est celle qui marchait
qui fonctionnait et qui nous donnait
notre fierté
l'europe que nous voulons c'est l'europe
projet l'europe pour laquelle nous nous
battons c'est l'europe civilisation
quand on vous demande quelle europe
voulez vous répondez nous voulons
l'europe de la civilisation et de
l'identité
c'est cette europe pour laquelle nous
nous engageons une civilisation une
civilisation d'abord ce sont des
frontières quand romulus et rémus fonde
rome il trace un sillon pour marquer
clairement que ce sont eux qui
décideront ce qu'ils rentreront à
l'intérieur de la cité romaine
l'europe c'est des frontières des
frontières ça veut dire qu'il ya des
limites et que l'europe ne peut pas
s'étendre à l'infini une de nos
différences majeures avec la liste dans
marche c'est que le président de la
république a proposé à trieste que les
pays des balkans intègre l'union
européenne une de nos différences
majeures par rapport au projet d'
emmanuel macron sait qu emmanuel macron
a accepté que les négociations avec
l'albanie l'albanie s'ouvre en juin
comme par hasard au lendemain de
l'élection européenne
eh bien nous tous ceux qui sont sur
notre liste et le savent
franck prennent avec moi un engagement
ils voteront contre toute décision
pendant leur mandat qui ouvrirait la
voie à tout élargissement
supplémentaires
tout élargissement supplémentaires et
nous portons de concert avec la cdu ou
notre partenaire allemand une
revendication claire on arrête une bonne
fois pour toutes les négociations avec
la turquie la turquie ça n'est pas dans
l'union européenne et on arrête ce
cinéma avec lequel on vit depuis trop
longtemps
connaître ses frontières c'est bien
défendre ses frontières
c'est tout aussi important oui le défi
migratoire est devant nous oui comme tu
l'as si bien rappelé le gouvernement
depuis deux ans n'a rien fait pire que
cela jamais notre pays n'a délivré
autant de titres de séjour plus de deux
cent cinquante mille titres de séjour
chaque année supplémentaire qui sont
délivrés ce qui représente l'équivalent
d'une ville de bordeaux
chaque année notre pays et le continent
européen ne peut pas faire face à une
telle l'immigration
nous avons dépassé nos capacités
d'intégration et nous devons de toute
urgence reprendre la maîtrise de la
politique migratoire
cela suppose de maîtriser à la fois ses
frontières européennes et ses frontières
nationales
je suis allé à vintimille pour aller
discuter avec les policiers qui essayent
de vrais tant bien que mal pour protéger
notre frontière à cet endroit avec
littaye je suis allé en grèce pour
discuter avec les policiers les
gardes-frontières qui essayent tant bien
que mal pour lutter contre l'immigration
qui nous vient de turquie
c'est le même travail c'est la même
cause c'est la même mission l'erreur que
commet marine le pen c'est qu'elle dit
il ne faut pas que ce soit l'europe qui
défendent nos frontières mais enfin
comment ne peut-elle pas comprendre que
quand ils rentrent par la grèce quand
ils rentrent par l'italie quand ils
rentrent par l'espagne ensuite il arrive
en france et que donc il est
indispensable qu'il y ait un travail
commun européen pour défendre nos
frontières européennes
cette indispensable
mais avec une clarté
l'objectif ce n'est pas d'accueillir les
bateaux des passeurs sur le continent
européen
c'est de les reconduire sur les côtes
africaines l'objectif ça n'est pas
d'avoir le double discours que tient le
ministre de l'intérieur qui chaque
semaine qui vient faire un peu plus sa
crédibilité
un ministre de l'intérieur qui déclarent
un jour que les ong sont complices des
passeurs et qui cinq jours plus tard
décide d'accueillir les migrants du
bateau cia y
mais comment peut-on croire à ce double
discours permanent nous le nôtre est
très claire les bateaux des passeurs
doivent être reconduits sur les côtes
africaines
les demandes les demandes d'asile
doivent être faites sur les côtes
africaines et non pas en europe parce
que quand les demandes d'asile sont
faites en europe c'est trop tard et
quand la justice dit que les gens n'ont
pas à rester en france
ils ne sont jamais reconduit à
l'étranger et donc c'est trop tard quand
les demandes d'asile sont faites chez
nous elles doivent être faite de l'autre
côté de la méditerranée et enfin il faut
sortir de cette prime à l'illégalité
quand un étranger venu irrégulièrement
en europe s'il est ensuite régularisés
et bien c'est un encouragement à bafouer
les règles et les lois de l'europe
adoptons le même principe simple et
clair qui est été adopté par l'australie
si quelqu'un est rentré irrégulièrement
sur le continent européen
il ne peut plus jamais être régularisés
parce que sinon on encourage ceux qui
bafouent nos propres règles et nos
propres lois
et ceci mes amis ceux ci j'en suis
convaincu c'est la seule chose qui
permet de redonner aussi un avenir à
l'afrique
je ne sous-estime rien des drames je
n'ai sous-estiment rien de la souffrance
de ces visages qu'on voit parfois la
frontière des visages hagards qui ont
fait parfois des milliers de kilomètres
pour arriver ici en étant des racines et
sans doute en ayant vécu des choses
terribles qui ont été amenées parfois à
saigner leur famille pour pouvoir payer
les passeurs et les mafias qui les ont
instrumentalisé et bien mes amis je vous
le dis la vraie générosité la vraie
générosité comme le disait si bien peggy
la vraie générosité c'est la fermeté est
rien et meurtriers comme la lâcheté
notre devoir c'est de faire en sorte que
le développement soit en afrique
notre devoir c'est d'aider le
développement humanitaire en afrique
notre devoir c'est de dire que l'avenir
de la jeunesse africaine est en afrique
ça c'est notre devoir
une civilisation ensuite ce sont des
ambitions communes
françois-xavier l'a si bien dit le
travail
l'europe des projets par celle des
normes je n'y reviendrai pas l'europe de
la santé jean pour laquelle tu te bats
une europe qui soit capable de faire
travailler ensemble nos laboratoires de
recherche pour lutter contre la maladie
d'alzheimer
cette europe que nous avons vu cet
après-midi et dont vous êtes un reflet
une europe qui croient dans l'audace une
europe qui croient dans le souffle une
europe qui croient dans l'initiative
cette europe qui s'est incarné avec ces
quelques visages croisés cet après midi
que j'ai tellement aimé
quant à sophia antipolis sur le site de
biotech vous avez un jeune qui a été
formé au bts de chimie de nice et qui
vient nous voir et qui nous dit moi je
suis fier de mon travail
j'adore la chimie c'est ma passion je
veux que l'europe puisse continuer à
découvrir des médicaments et les remèdes
de demain pour continuer à faire
progresser la santé mais qu'est ce que
ça fait du bien de voir quelqu'un qui
aime son travail qui croient dans ce qui
fait et qui en est fier
quand on était david sur le chantier de
ce superbe campus universitaire que vous
êtes tous en train de bâtir avec cette
belle coopération entre les communes sur
ce site de cannes où vous allez faire un
des plus beaux au campus universitaire
qui va permettre demain de forme et
peut-être les scénaristes de geniki
redresseront l'industrie du cinéma
européen et français et qu'il y ait un
chef de chantier qui vient et qui nous
dit venez avec moi je vais vous montrer
mon béton regardez comme il est beau et
comme on a fait un beau travail
c'est cette europe que j'aime c'est
celle du travail c'est pas celle des
normes
c'est une europe qui ne croient pas au
fait que l'on devienne un pays un
continent
mon pouce des caddies à acheter des
produits qui ont été fait partout
ailleurs sauf chez nous je crois à
l'europe du travail dans une europe dans
laquelle tout n'est pas à jeter dans
lequel le corps humain n'est pas une
marchandise et dans laquelle on reprend
confiance et où on comprend que le vrai
social c'est le travail
je ne veux pas d'une europe dans lequel
plus personne ne veut travailler et
c'est pour cela que je revendique que
chez nous il y est toujours un équilibre
entre les droits et les devoirs et que
quand on bénéficie de la solidarité
nationale
on puisse aussi travaillé pour rendre
une partie de ce qu'on a reçu et enfin
mes amis je finirai par là une
civilisation c'est une identité
c'est une tradition c'est une culture
commune
cette tradition cette identité cette
civilisation comment ne pas voir qu'elle
est aujourd'hui menacée elle est menacée
c'est sans doute le plus grave pour nous
elle est menacé par des gens qui parfois
sont nés sur le continent européen
elle est menacé par des gens auxquels
nous avons tout donné
auxquels l'europe a offert toute sa
générosité et qui ont tourné leur haine
et leur arme contre ce que nous sommes
et qui déteste
aujourd'hui tout ce que nous avons voulu
leur transmettre
la guerre contre l'islamisme est une
guerre dans laquelle il ne peut pas y
avoir de répit ni de l'acheter la guerre
contre l'islamisme à l'est celle de
l'europe suppose de prendre les mesures
qui s'imposent les mesures qui
s'imposent ce sont des mesures de
fermeté enfin c'est pour cela que nous
proposons qu'il y ait un pacte européen
contre l'islamisme que ce pacte européen
contre l'islamisme reposent sur des
décisions de bon sens la première
décision de bon sens s'est d'abord de
fermer toutes les mosquées salafistes
qui sont en europe toutes les mosquées
salafistes qui sont en europe
la deuxième mesure qui s'impose c'est
celle d'empêcher aux imams qui prêchent
la haine de continuer à prêcher tous les
vendredis comment pouvons nous accepter
qu'il continue à faire cela comme nous
le faisons eric michel gens quand la
république instaurée la laïcité elle a
fait preuve de fermeté et la religion
catholique a été capable de comprendre
qu'elle devait s'adapter à ce que
demandait la république eh bien il est
évident que nous devons faire preuve de
la même fermeté à l'égard des prêcheurs
de haine et que nous devons leur
interdire de continuer à prêcher leur
travail de sape et de propagande à
l'ombre des mosquées et enfin mes amis
comment comprendre que le gouvernement
français a accepté de faire revenir sur
le sol français 200 jihadistes
nous revendiquons qui dit un travail
qu'ils soient très claires de la part de
l'europe que l'europe oeuvre en lien
avec l'irak pour qu'il y ait un tribunal
international qui soit installée en irak
que ce tribunal international permettent
de juger les djihadistes qui ont commis
leur crime en irak et en syrie
là-bas qu'il soit condamné sur le sol
irakien et qu'ils restent sur le sol
irakien
ils ont trahi la france et l'europe ils
ne doivent pas revenir en france et en
europe
et parce que je n'aime pas les faux
semblants
je vais aussi que vous sachiez qu'aucune
de ces mesures n'a été soutenu par
marine le pen
quant au niveau du parlement européen
une proposition a été faite pour faire
en sorte que l'europe se dote d'un
logiciel permettant de suivre et de
détecter les mouvements des terroristes
pour les empêcher notamment de pouvoir
embarquer dans des aéroports
marine le pen a refusé de voter cette
disposition et a expliqué qu'elle ne le
faisait pas parce que les terroristes ne
prenez pas l'avion
honte à marine le pen d'avoir osé dire
cela après les attentats du 11 septembre
il y à bien deux visages sur le front
national pour marine le pen
elle est tellement contre l'europe
qu'elle est contre l'europe y compris
quand elles y sacrifier les intérêts de
la france madame le pen évidemment que
les terroristes prennent l'avion
les frères kwasi avait pris l'avion et
les terroristes qui ont envoyé ces
avions contre les tours des twin towers
à new york
qu'avait-il prix comment peut-on être à
ce point là irresponsables et
incompétents
retenir la leçon de notre dame
françois-xavier retrouver le droit
d'aimer ce que nous sommes
comment at-on pu en arriver là comment
ne peut-on pas comprendre qu'une
civilisation aussi merveilleuse que la
nôtre qu'une culture aussi merveilleuse
que la nôtre issus de trois racines tout
aussi estimable les racines de
l'antiquité les racines judéo
chrétiennes les racines des lumières
comment ne pas comprendre que notre
devoir c'est de la transmettre
nous sommes ici au bord de la
méditerranée vous avez toute légitimité
à être infiniment fier de ce que
représente ce petit bout de terre
européenne et son apport unique
vous êtes les héritiers d'une fondation
qui a été fait par des colons grecs qui
ont étendu la démocratie et qu'il entend
installer ici sur ces petits bords de la
méditerranée vous êtes les héritiers de
ce fruit extraordinaire de l' empire
romain qui avait fait de cette petite
partie de l' empire romain un de ses
joyaux qui était à l'époque appelé la
provincia romana vous êtes les héritiers
de ce mouvement magnifique qui est
partie ici de saint-honorat comme tu me
le rappelait de ce mouvement cisterciens
parti d'ici et qui a permis petit à
petit de christianiser toute l'europe et
de la couvrir de ce manteau d'églises et
de cathédrales qui font que quand nous
nous déplaçons dans un autre pays et que
l'on reconnaît un clocher que l'on
reconnaît la silhouette familière d'une
cathédrale
on sait alors qu'on est en europe vous
êtes les héritiers de ceux qui dans une
terre hostile ont lutté contre les
barbaresques ont lutté contre les
pirateries n'ont jamais renoncé ont
systématiquement reconstruit les
villages qui avait été détruit et qui
avait été attaqué vous êtes le fruit
magnifique de ce mouvement séculaire
avec lequel petit à petit la france est
édifié et la france a su qu'elle était
au bout de la démarche de construction
de l'état nation
quand enfin le comté de nice avait
intégré la république et la nation
française avec le travail qui avait été
fait à l'époque par le second empire
vous êtes les héritiers de tout cela
vous êtes les héritiers de cette lumière
magique qui a illuminé les peintres
français et qui leur ont permis ensuite
d'émerveiller le monde c'est pas prêts
extraordinaires bonnart bien sûr matisse
chagall les impressionnistes qui ont ici
appris à chérir la lumière unique qui
existe dans la méditerranée évidemment
pas seulement l'été mais dans ces
moments extraordinaires de transition
entre deux saisons où tout d'un coup
quand on tourne le regard vers la grande
bleue
on est ébloui par cette lumière unique
au monde vous êtes les héritiers de tout
cela vous êtes les héritiers aussi de
cette audace extraordinaire qui est
celle de cette terre qui n'avait rien
pour réussir et qui est petit à petit
devenu un eldorado
au nom de quoi aurions-nous honte de ce
que nous sommes
au nom de quoi aurions-nous honte de
notre mode de vie nous avons toute
légitimité à être fiers nous avons toute
légitimité a demandé que cette histoire
cette culture ce mode de vie soit
respectée parce qu'ils viennent sur le
continent européen et qui viennent en
terre française
et oui françois-xavier tu l'as dit il y
à des incendies comme l' incendie de
notre dame
mais il ya aussi des incendies plus
invisible il y à des destructions plus
silencieuse il y à des destructions
qu'elle nous ne prêtons pas garde
parce qu'elles ne font pas
nécessairement la une de l'actualité et
pour autant elles sont tout aussi graves
quand on accepte que dans une salle de
classe on ne puisse plus faire un voyage
à reims parce qu'on explique que ça
n'est pas compatible avec la religion de
certains cantons acceptent que dans une
salle de classe
on ne puisse plus enseigner l'histoire
de la shoah alors c'est un petit
incendie
quand un président de la république va
de l'autre côté de la rive de la
méditerranée et que insultant ainsi la
mémoire de bien des familles qui ont
tout perdu
il explique qu'en algérie la france
n'aurait commis que des crimes contre
l'humanité alors nous renonçons à une
petite partie de ce que nous sommes
comme dans un hôpital on accepte qu'une
femme ne puisse pas être soigné par un
médecin homme parce que son mari
explique que ça n'est pas compatible
avec sa religion
quand un de nos dans un de nos quartiers
une femme n'a pas le choix et qu'elle
doit se couvrir la tête parce que
certains décident à sa place
ce qu'est sa liberté ce qu'est son droit
ce qu'est sa légitimité à travailler ou
non cette un petit incendie à chaque
fois que nous reculons sur un bout de
notre identité et de ce que nous sommes
c'est un petit bout d'un incendie
pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai jamais voulu
céder sur cette question en apparence
anecdotique des crèches
parce que je suis convaincu qu'à chaque
fois que l'on recule c'est un petit bout
de ce que nous sommes que nous perdons
je ne veux plus que nous reculions je ne
veux plus que nous reculions alors oui
mes amis
il faut retrouver le vrai sens de
l'intégration ce sens de l'intégration
merveilleux donc plusieurs ici pour être
témoignée et qui a fait que la france
l'europe a été capable d'accueillir des
générations qui venaient de l'étranger
et qui venaient en disant ce mot
merveilleux à leurs enfants
à compter de ce jour ton pays c'est la
france ton continent
c'est l'europe nous avons commis une
erreur funeste en inversant le devoir
d'intégration et en croyant que la
tolérance c'était au contraire nous
de changer c'est exactement l'inversé
qu'il faut faire
la vraie tolérance la vraie générosité
c'est d'expliquer à ceux qui viennent ce
qu'est notre mode de vie c'est de leur
transmettre notre culture et de notre
histoire et de leur dire à compter de ce
jour c'est la vôtre et vous devez la
respecter oui mes amis c'est cela notre
bataille
c'est cela notre combat notre combat
c'est de rappeler à chacun de nos
habitants à chacun des pays européens
qu'ils sont les héritiers de cette
grande histoire et de cette belle
culture et que d'être un héritier
c'est à la fois une source de fierté et
qu'en même temps ça oblige nous devons
tout à la fois être fiers et être digne
notre histoire ce n'est pas notre passé
notre histoire c'est notre avenir
la seule façon d'organiser l'avenir de
l'europe et de la réconcilier avec son
passé pour lui donner à nouveau l'audace
de se projeter vers les lendemains
c'est cette europe dont je veux c'est ce
combat que je vous demande de relever
dans cette campagne il y à quelque chose
qui est en train de bouger
il y à un moment électrique qui est en
train de s'installer il y à des
pronostics qui sont en train de se
déjouer il y à ce moment que l'on
connaît ou tous les commentateurs tout
d'un coup sont ébahis et en se disant
tiens quelque chose se passe là où nous
ne l'attendions pas oui il y a un espoir
qui est en train de se lever de notre
côté ce moment c'est le nôtre et demain
ce sera une force que personne ne pourra
arrêter
il vous reste 24 jours pour tout donner
vingt-quatre jours pour amplifier cette
dynamique 24 jours pour dénouer tous les
pronostics
vingt-quatre jours pour mener le seul
combat qui vaille celui qui permet de se
battre tout à la fois pour refonder
l'europe et rétablir la france je ne
connais pas de plus beau combat
quand on s'engage en politique nous
avons besoin de vous vive l'europe et
vive la france
pour
elle
nous
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]